it had been getting slower the longer
the days weeks months and years went on
the more time it took to move before
long before the collapse it used to move
like lightning in the blink of a human
eye it could go from one side of a room
to the other it had moved with such
speed that it looked to have disappeared
from one place and reappeared in another
by the time the same human's eye
reopened there it would be standing
before them and as they realized that
they had to strain to keep their eyes
open and stare at it it would wait until
they inevitably had to Blink again that
was when it would strike but now its
movements were getting sluggish it had
been able to move around of its own
volition for some time after the
collapse unobserved and thus free for
the first time in a long while yet now
it was succumbing to the one thing it
couldn't move faster than the one thing
that makes dust of all things time a
sound suddenly and faintly but
undoubtedly caused by movement a human a
victim it turned to see the man enter
the room stopping still as his gaze fell
over it all it had to do was wait the
agent could barely believe his eyes the
second he'd spotted the sculpture he'd
instinctively froze to the spot rigid
with sheer Terror heart drumming against
his rib cage standing across the room
from it directly opposite he kept
himself as still as the concrete and
rebar statue was the agent knew that as
long as he looked at it it couldn't move
he just had to make sure he didn't so
much as blink or at least that's how it
used to work to his horror the agent
noticed that the arm of SCP 173 started
to slowly reach towards him but how how
had the sculpture an anomaly one capable
of moving only while unobserved found a
way to suddenly start reaching for this
agent well for a start that is something
to do with the particular Foundation
operative who was looking at SCP
173 and technically wasn't at the same
time let us start at the beginning you
see some time ago a former field agent
working at the SCP Foundation suffered
quite an unprecedented accident let's
call him Daryl a seemingly average man
in his 30s while as average as someone
working for the foundation can be
however one Mission would unexpectedly
change Daryl's life forever turning him
into SCP
451 it started as a straightforward
retrieval operation Daryl was instructed
to recover a dangerous anomalous
artifact however he ultimately failed
and was declared missing an action as a
result that is until he miraculously
resurfaced a month later at site 19
but from Daryl's point of view the
entire Foundation facility looked like
it had been deserted corridors and Labs
that had previously been bustling hives
of activity were now unsettlingly empty
scps seemed to still be in their
containment Chambers but without anyone
watching or guarding them as far as SCP
451 knew he was the only man still alive
on Earth some anomalous influence had
left him with a unique Affliction a
permanently altered perception Daryl was
rendered incapable of seeing other human
beings it wasn't just limited to his
sight either he couldn't hear anyone or
even perceive their existence any
attempts the foundation's researchers
made to communicate with ascp 451 were
unsuccessful they could still see him
but it was like he was absent standing
just outside the real world and yet to
Daryl it was somehow worse than that
given the lack of people around him him
being unable to see hear or interact
with anyone SCP 451 quickly adopted the
belief that by interacting with the
anomalous artifact he had
single-handedly wiped out the entire
human race while this wasn't true he had
no way of knowing that everyone else was
still alive he just couldn't perceive
them the guilt instilled in Daryl
weighed heavily on the agent's
conscience he spent a lot of time
wandering the corridors of site 19
overwhelmed by his apparent eyes olation
convinced he'd single-handedly caused
the extinction of the human race but
what does SCP 451 have to do with SCP
173 how did Daryl go from being unable
to see and hear other humans to staring
down the sculpture well while Daryl was
suffering from his newly altered
perception something catastrophic was
unfolding in The Wider world he could
hardly interact with anymore an end of
the world scenario had taken place and
left barely any survivors making the
perceived Extinction of humanity by SCP
451 oddly prophetic something had caused
the human race to actually die out and
with nobody around who could explain
what had happened the actual how and why
were forgotten to history and even if
someone had managed to survive SCP 451
would still be as oblivious to their
explanations as he was to the disaster
that claimed the lives of not only the
whole SCP Foundation but the rest of the
world too of course without the
foundation and its Personnel around any
longer to safeguard the rest of humanity
or even anything left of humanity for
them to protect things quickly got even
worse the various contained scps soon
found themselves free to run a muck
whatever had wiped the human race from
existence left the world mostly
uninhabited and it didn't take long for
some of the more aggressive anomalies to
turn on each other with no humans for
them to pray on they had to make do but
while they fought killed and died in the
ruins of the world one was left to roam
Freer than it had ever been SCP
173 now that the sculpture was no longer
caged by the foundation it could move
around unobserved before it would be
frozen in place whenever Personnel
entered its cell to clean it every 2
weeks constantly watching it to stop it
from moving but now there were no
Personnel after the human race had been
wiped out SCP 173 set about bursting
free from its container it took quite
some time using its heavy concrete and
rebar arms to Dent the walls from within
continually pounding on the metal until
it eventually gave way bursting free SCP
173 found itself in a world with hardly
anyone around to look at it and that
meant it could go anywhere it wanted do
anything it pleased so long as none of
the the other surviving scps came across
it that did happen from time to time of
course any of the more humanoid
anomalies that were capable of sight
would sometimes stumble upon the
sculpture but they had to bling sometime
and when they did SCP 173 would
effortlessly zip over to where they
stood and break their necks exercising
its Newfound Freedom as CP 173 moved
unnoticed to the office of Dr alto clef
the INF famously unh hinged Foundation
researcher weapons fanatic and
specialist in decommissioning
scps C like the rest of the human race
was nowhere to be found when the
sculpture burst into his office if it
had the capacity for emotions maybe it
felt angered even cheated to find that
cleft was gone it had seemed to have
come seeking revenge for a number of
years Dr cleff had been infatuated with
SCP 173 were he still alive clef himself
would have described the anomalous
statue as a former flame someone he had
a bond with although he had no idea how
one-sided his feelings truly were the
sculpture if it could feel would have
been indifferent towards the crazed
researcher were it not for date night
cleff had on a number of occasions
dressed as CP 173 in a black dress and a
blonde wig and shared romantic evenings
in its company it's never been known if
SCP b173 is just an object with
anomalous movement Properties or if the
sculpture is an actual living creature
with sentience but if it was then no
doubt being made to go on repeated dates
with Dr clef would have humiliated SCP
173 and as it searched clef's office
while it couldn't find the loathsome
researcher it did find a certain black
dress and wig that the sculpture quickly
crushed under the weight of its heavy
Stony arms it wasn't Dr cleft being
smashed but it was enough meanwhile SCP
451 still remained completely unaware
that everyone else was gone to him
nothing had changed he still couldn't
perceive anyone not that there was
anyone around anyway he'd witnessed a
lot of Destruction unfurled by the
anomalous breaking their containment but
most didn't pay Daryl any mind ones that
did quickly found they couldn't interact
with him or cause the former Foundation
agent harm and quickly lost interest in
him that was an added torturous part of
SCP 41's condition he couldn't die a
long time before the end of the world
scenario Daryl had found a firearm
belonging to another member of
foundation Personnel in the main break
room of site9 as SCP 451 tried to fire
the weapon the bullet ricocheted off the
wall and The Gunshot passed directly
through him the same bullet mortally
wounded another nearby member of
foundation's staff and it was after he'd
accidentally injured this unsuspecting
researcher that SCP 451 found he was
briefly able to interact with them right
as the researcher's life was fading that
was the last time he'd been able to see
anyone well any human anyway but then he
encountered SCP
173 the pair of them came face to face
with each other in the ruins of a
foundation site by that point the
overwhelming loneliness of believing
himself to be Humanity's Soul Survivor
had already taken a bad toll on Daryl he
was losing himself every day getting
more and more overwhelmed by the
anomalous hell he was living SCP 173 was
caught for a moment when SCP 451 walked
in on it stuck fast like it had been
whenever someone observed it but as
Daryl stared and tried not to Blink the
sculpture found itself still able to
move it could see SCP 451 and he could
see it yet it could still move somehow
due to the way Daryl's perception had
been anomalously altered it affected the
way he saw the sculpture it was almost
like he was seeing it without seeing it
had been so long since Humanity
disappeared that the sculptures
movements had been gradually getting
slower the rebar holding it together had
been rusting creaking more as it bent
and twisted its concrete parts were
starting to crumble away and now despite
being free it was struggling just to
reach reach an arm out to SCP 451 to
kill him for his part SCP 451 had been
forced to live out a painful existence
spending each and every day alone as
delirium had begun to sink its claws
into him Daryl had wished for one thing
some company and now he'd found it
misinterpreting scp1 73's arm extending
towards him SCP 451 broke down crying
and embraced the sculpture his tears ran
down the the anomalous statue's decaying
concrete body the struts in its arms
creaking as it tried to reach for darl
but the sculpture was getting old too
old to kill as quick as it used to time
and loneliness two of the most painful
things to experience the side effect of
and yet while SCP 173 continued to
wither it was unknowingly helping
alleviate someone else's pain although
it could still move while SCP 451 looked
at it Daryl didn't leave the sculpture
alone in his mind driven half mad by
being isolated for so long he genuinely
believed that SCP 173 and he were
friends the sculpture had spared him
after all SCP 451 had no idea what had
happened to the rest of the human race
and the other scps now loose on the
world barely acknowledged him but in the
concrete and rebar statue he found a
friend SCP 451 followed scp1 73 as it
shuffled itself away not leaving its
side matching the slowed speed of its
Stony scraping movements as they
wandered together darl poured his heart
out about everything and anything glad
to have someone anyone to talk to even
if the sculpture couldn't reply again
nobody knows for sure if SCP 173 was an
object or a living creature but if it
was the latter then there's still no
telling how it perceived as CP 451 it
could have taken pity on him maybe
sympathizing with his plight and
begrudgingly alleviating his Solitude or
it might have found Daryl to be a
nuisance we'll never know and neither
would SCP 451 as the years passed SCP
173 continued to slow down and kept
withering portions of its concrete body
crumbled until they were little more
than dust the metal wired through the
sculpture rusted eventually coming to a
stop what was was left of SCP 173
stopped moving fixed to one spot where
it would stay forever still not
realizing it had perished as CP 451 sat
beside it and kept talking hello one and
all and welcome back to the
anamatronic for projecting any seemingly
improbable scenario for your viewing
Indulgence and today we decided to do
something slightly different with it
here at SCP explained we usually
activate the
anamatronic Denis of the SCP universe
and other fictional characters like
Doctor Strange fighting the Scarlet king
or AEL crossing paths with Batman but
this
entering the input Booth of the
anomalous refinement machine during a
Containment Breach what emerged was
maybe the handsomest man to ever live
Beautiful both on the outside and within
a lot of our comments pointed out that
this refined version of 096 felt akin to
a gigachad and that got us thinking what
if scp096 was to encounter the real
gigachad well the
anamatronic one or as we like to call it
the obvious outcome pits the thin
humanoid anomaly Against The Man Behind
the meme Ernest COV is a Russian fitness
trainer and model forever immortalized
in the animals of Internet history by a
series of black and white photoshopped
pictures that garnered him the nickname
of gigachad thanks to his Practically
Perfect 90° jawline and muscular
physique kov seemingly unknowingly
became the archetype for the Ultram
masculine handsome man however The Man
Behind the gigachad meme is still just a
man the infamous photos of him were
heavily edited for an art project known
as sleek and tears and while Ernest does
Sport some impressive muscles from all
his time at the gym that strength isn't
enough to save him from the shy guy
after all he is still just a man
according to the
anamatronics the most likely outcome if
the two were ever to meet would end
pretty similarly to the Grim fate of
many others who have gazed upon the face
of scp's 096 the moment Ernest looks at
the creature he would in all likelihood
activate 0 96's rage State his physique
and above average level of Fitness might
give him a slight Advantage allowing him
to perhaps outrun the shy guy for longer
than most but ultimately Ernest kov
would be able to run but not hide from
scp096 the creature would track him down
and hone in on him with anomalous speed
dispatching him before returning to its
usual docile side loing State the result
and scp096
victory now we know what you're thinking
is that really it we had the same
Reaction 2 but hold on for a minute
after giving the machine an additional
set of variables we were able to get a
few more interesting outcomes out of the
anamatronic 2 shy harder of course
Ernest kov might be the face of an
internet meme and ultimately just a very
strong Russian man in comparison into
the anomalous traits of scp096 but the
gigachad the gigachad is more than a man
so much more than the some of his Parts
existing within the online zge since as
early as 2017 the gigachad is far more
powerful than a mere mortal he doesn't
just represent idealized standards of
overe exaggerated masculinity like the
Action Movie heroes of the 1980s the
gigachad embodies those ideas he is the
very notion of a physically perfected
human specimen given form you may not
like it but Peak Performance doesn't
even come close to the gigachad and
neither does scp096 even at the top of
its game the creature quite literally
pales in comparison to its imposing
opponent in scenario 2 shy harder the
anamatronic that if the two were to meet
the scales would tip in the complete
opposite direction from the first
outcome for that was scp096
against the man but against the meme
himself well this fight is no contest as
a matter of fact it's hardly even a
fight certainly not a fair one and
instead is more of an execution from the
moment the Unstoppable Tower of muscle
and perfect angular jawline that is the
gigachad clasps eyes on scp096 it's
practically the beginning of the end the
shy guy doesn't even lift bro but
gigachad can bench 1 million times his
own own body weight in his sleep so when
scp096 comes racing towards him intent
on killing him just for looking at its
screeching wide jawed face the gigachad
does what the gigachad does best he
lifts grabbing SC scp096 with ease as it
comes to him screeching gigachad
casually hoists the creature off the
ground although he's only using the
tiniest portion of his immense and
Infinite Strength it's more than enough
Force to send the shy gu soaring upwards
crashing through multiple ceilings as it
sent hurdling up the numerous floors of
the foundation facility above of course
being lifted is hardly going to kill the
shy guy outright the creature is known
to be invulnerable after all but it's
not like gigachad can go down easily
either don't forget this is no mere
mortal but an internet meme incarnate
and on the internet nothing ever dies
his Perpetual existence as part of
online history aside the gigachad is so
strong that no doubt his abs could
withstand the Firepower of any
conventional weapon realizing that even
if it could reach him it couldn't even
scratch the gigachad scp096 would
undoubtedly begin a downward spiral the
shy guy is a creature so insecure in
itself and its appearance that it kills
anyone who so much as glances at its
face in photos so being presented with
the living embodiment of an idea it
could never even hope to attain the
biceps the perfect right angled jawline
it's all too much sending scp096 into a
complete meltdown the creature would be
neutralized once and for all by the very
existence of the gigachad resulting in
his victory okay so we're 1 point to
scp096 and one 12 gigachad and most
people would maybe consider leaving it
there but not us we wanted more than
that you see we quickly realized that
the
of the gigachad meme don't get us wrong
that version of the ultimate man could
still easily destroy the shy guy but
around March of 20121 the infamous
photoshopped images of Ern kov started
to be used in slightly different formats
that's the thing about memes they're not
only Immortal forever logged in the
ancient texts of the Wayback machine and
compilation videos here on YouTube but
memes are also adaptable they can evolve
and change finding new variations as
time goes on
as such the average fan versus average
enjoyer meme saw a new use of the
gigachad before the gigachad this notion
of the ideal ultr masculine specimen was
based on let's be honest some pretty
outdated ideas about what it means to be
a man after all it takes more than
muscle to be a man not every man or
masculine presenting person has to work
out until they're built like a brick
wall perhaps the real Measure of a Man
is how sincere sensitive and supportive
you can be as well as standing by your
interests rather than caving to Old
societal standards of masculinity and
after we updated our data the
anamatronic outcome or what we like to
call scenario 3 the average scp096
enjoyer in this projection the Giga
Chad's true strength isn't just his
masculine physique and his unattainable
standards instead it's in in part the
inherent adaptability of his status as a
meme but also his compassion just like
before he's more than able to resist SC
SCP 96's attacks and the creature's
insecurity comes out put on full display
when presented with gigachad sharp
jawline but rather than overcome his
anomalous adversary by fighting him this
scenario sees the gigachad comforting
the shy guy through calm empathy and
words of affirmation he reminds SC
scp096
that true acceptance of oneself comes
from within and that message strikes a
chord with the creature in a turn of
events none of us saw coming the Giga
Chad offers to help scp096 overcome his
crippling and deadly sense of insecurity
the pairs start using the on-site gym
together after hours when there aren't
any innocent Foundation Personnel around
there Giga Chad not only offers to
introduce scp096 to an exercise regimen
if that's what the creature wants but
also helps the shy guy work on his
confidence they form a friendship with
scp096 taking a liking to working out
not because it wants to be buff like its
new friend the gigachad but more so
because doing so makes it feel more
comfortable in its own skin scp096
gradually starts to like itself more
even eating healthier thanks to Giga
Chad's advice eventually the shy guy
begins looking far more content and even
starts to develop self-confidence it's
not not often that a story involving
scp096 exists with the creature getting
to achieve some semblance of Happiness
well there is one that comes to mind the
very same Shy Guy story that sent us on
this particular streak of pitting it
against the gigachad in the first place
but what if we put them together would
coming across a refined scp096 spell the
N for the gigachad or would the muscular
masculine meme undo the shy gu's
previous happy ending well according to
the anomet 6000 neither when we last
left him after being turned into a
handsome 9t tall man scp096 had just
started going by the name David SCP 978
the desired camera had been used to
photograph the refined Shy Guy it showed
him holding hands with the foundation
scientist responsible for his
transformation who had studied the new
and improved scp096 in great detail she
had quite the understanding of him but
perhaps the photograph from the Desir
camera was more of a metaphor and what
scp096 or David really desired wasn't
specifically the researcher who' studied
him but a partner who understood him
someone to call an equal enter the
gigachad according to the calculations
made by the
for and an immovable object neither one
rushed to solve the encounter with
violence both the gigachad and scp096
appreciated each other's aesthetic
appeal both were remarkably handsome and
one couldn't bear the thought of ridding
the world of the other instead it was
love at first sight both David formerly
known as scp096 and the gigachad fell
head over heels in love with each other
and looking at both it was not hard to
see why they were a PA air of fine
perfectly chiseled fellas and they
instantly hit it off the newly
established couple enjoyed each other's
company spending time and deep
conversations scp096 introducing his new
partner to his friends at the foundation
while gigachad was comfortable with his
own masculinity to express his feelings
towards David without fear or judgment
no relationship is perfect of course for
a short time a sliver of David's old
self reemerged the shy guy in him
worried that perhaps his relationship
with the gigachad was based purely on
both of their extreme good looks and was
nothing more than superficial but by
being an embodiment of healthy idealized
masculinity the gigachad was able to
sense something was wrong with David and
rather due the insecure thing of letting
it Fester he addressed it directly and
they discussed the issue in a healthy
mature and constructive way not just so
they could put scp096 as worry to rest
but so that both of them could further
strengthen their relationship and grow
as people and of course gigachad wasn't
just attracted to scp096 is refine good
looks far from being superficial he
recognized that David was a complete
person beautiful both inside and out and
loved him as a whole not just because
they were both conventionally attractive
on the surface scp096 and the gigachad
stayed together for the rest of their
lives or as we decided to name this
fourth scenario from the anom
happily ever after panic and Terror
gripped everyone in the foundation
facility Well everyone who was still
alive that is guards were working
tirelessly to fight back and regain
control of the building but they didn't
have enough bullets to surpress the
oncoming horde somehow a sample of SCP
008 that was being examined for testing
purposes had managed to spread to one of
the research staff before long the very
same researcher was now a Mindless
zombie a reanimated corpse that had
managed to bite several other staff
members spreading the infection it
didn't matter that this original carrier
was shot down by security Personnel it
had already done its damage and passed
on SCP
008 by now there were too many of them
to Simply Bonk each one on the head and
neutralize it the foundation facility
had gone into fullscale lockdown an
emergency quarantine to try and limit
the spread of the deadly virus any exit
to the outside world was shut and would
stay sealed tight until someone from the
foundation could do something but that
meant the few surviving members of Staff
trapped inside were at the mercy of the
zombie horde their options were limited
SCP 500 was known to perfectly cure
those infected with SCP 008 but with all
exits locked it was impossible to get
any of the remaining SCP 500 pills on
site then one of the surviving
researchers one Dr om had an idea it was
an insanely risky plan one that the
foundation would never sign off on but
desperate times called for desperate
measures Gathering up the remaining
security forces that hadn't been
infected with SCP 008 along with a
research assistant that had managed to
escape the Zombies Dr oml and his band
of survivors headed deeper into the
facility while the external doors were
all locked to prevent the SCP 008
infectees from making it out and
spreading the virus to The Wider world
the doors inside the facility were all
still functioning and it was a good
thing too drl's plan relied on opening
the doors to two anomalies SCP 914 the
Clockworks a machine capable of
destroying or refining anything placed
inside of it and SCP 049 the plague
doctor it was a shot in the dark at
bestel had observed the plague doctor
for some time and knew that the beak
face surgeon was capable of creating
zombie-like creatures known as SCP
049-2 not dissimilar from the zombies
infected with SCP 008 if anyone could
potentially fix this nightmare there
were few as well versed in anomalous
medicine as SCP 049 taking him to the
Clockworks was however an even bigger
risk normally SC SCP 049 killed any he
touched and turned their deceased bodies
into SCP
049-2 hence Dr RL calling for a
refinement of the plague doctor's
abilities placing him in the input Booth
of SCP 914 and setting it to very fine
oml prayed he'd made the right call he
could hear the horde of SCP 008 pounding
outside the locked door what emerged
from the Clockworks was still
recognizable as SCP 049 retaining his
beaked mask although the mask itself was
actually flesh and Bone a part of his
skull his robes now float out behind him
as a pair of dark feathery Wings giving
him an even more bird-like appearance
despite this SCP 049 had claimed that
he'd never been a bird before I'll admit
I didn't expect Wings the surviving
assistant remarked that's not so
surprising really Dr RL admitted he did
lay an egg that one time what he did
what before an explanation could be
given the SCP 008 zombies managed to
break down the door and came flooding
into the rooml recoiled in horror as
they snarled and shuffled closer
reaching towards him with decrepit
fingers suddenly SC SCP 049 swooped into
the path of the encroaching Undead with
a flap of his new Wings calmly he gave a
gentle move of his hand like lifting
something from a shelf a bizarre
Contraption appeared around his forearm
a gauntlet connected to syringes that
were strapped to each of his fingers all
filled with various different fluids Dr
omel was amazed SCP 049 seemed to now
have have the anomalous ability to
summon surgical equipment from a tiny
pocket Dimension it was almost exactly
like how SCP 076 st2 AEL drew his
weapons reaching towards the nearest SCP
008 zombie still moving with the utmost
calm SCP 049 stated now try to hold
still he spoke in a gentle voice with a
bedside manner most medical doctors
would be incapable of This Might Sting a
little with that SCP 049 pushed the
syringes into the zombie the fluids
draining from each one then refilling as
he withdrew his hand the SCP 08 instance
froze for a moment almost like it was
confused before it began to admit what
looked to be steam as though it had
stepped out of a hot shower shaking
uncontrollably the necrosis and telltale
signs of infection seemed to disappear
like being washed away until all that
was left of the SCP 008 zombie was the
infected researcher it had been before
before the man was alive and well much
to Dr om's astonishment SCP 049 hadn't
just cured the SCP 008 infection he'd
actually reversed it leaving the infecte
alive and well it took a few hours for
SCP 049 to fly around the facility on
his new Wings effortlessly turning all
the SCP 008 zombies back into their old
selves one by one by the time he was
done everyone on site that had
previously been exposed to SCP 008 was
cured and it didn't stop there the
foundation still mandated everyone who
was previously infected to remain in
quarantine whilst they were examined
demanding the now refined SCP 049 to
remain in a Cell which he politely
complied with when the SCP Foundation
doctors took a look at the formerly
zombified staff they were amazed at what
they found each one had all traces of
SCP 008 completely removed from their
systems trying to reexpose them to the
virus their bodies now seem to be able
to generate anomalous antibodies that
rejected and fought off infection by SCP
008 in a manner of seconds the plague
doctor had made everyone immune upon
further testing examining skin and blood
cells from the former infectees and
Performing full top to bottom health
checks the foundation doctors learned
something else too everyone that SCP 049
had cured was even healthier than they
had been before one security guard had
been a one pack a day smoker for 10
years but an x-ray revealed any damage
to his lungs mouth and throat had all
been completely reversed on every
possible internal and external level the
formerly zombified Personnel had all
been returned to pristine Health by a CP
049 eager to witness the full extent of
these new anomalous abilities the
Clockworks had given him the SCP
Foundation struck a deal with SCP 049 if
he performed a mission for them then
they would provide him with the means to
have anything he wanted for a moment the
plague doctor pondered their terms and
then agreed what is it you want in
return Dr omel had asked to cure the
world doctor SCP 049 replied simply the
plague doctor flew as fast as his wings
would carry him to the location the
foundation had given him it was an
isolated region in Siberia kept
completely cut off from the rest of the
World by guards working around the clock
arriving at the edge of the Frozen Town
SCP 049 was approached by the security
commander and given his full directive
from the foundation your objective I'm
told is simple you enter the restricted
area and neutralize anything you come
into contact with when you're done
return here and we'll report the results
to command thank you Commander the
plague doctor nodded graciously you have
been most helpful he didn't ask what was
out there merely turned and began
walking through the snow until he could
no longer be seen by the eye maybe he
had already sensed what was out there
what kind of sickness plagued this place
and understood exactly what the
foundation were asking him to do if SCP
049 had any questions he did not make
them known instead he just headed off in
search of every instance of SCP 610 he
could find there was quiet for an
uncomfortably long while the Personnel
standing guard at the edge of the area
watched through the snowfall ready if
anything thing started slithering its
way towards them the foundation's
security all tensed when the motion
sensor picked up movement accompanied by
the sounds of fighting and the bizarre
inhuman noises from instances of SCP 610
then after another long period of
unsettling quiet somebody spotted a
gently glowing light making its way
through the snow as it drew closer the
glow of a burning makeshift torch made
it clear that the figure holding it was
SCP 049 and as as he made his way
towards the rendevu point it quickly
became apparent he wasn't alone
shivering in the freezing cold and wet
from the snow covered in scraps of dirty
clothing and whatever else they could
find was a huddled mass of people all of
them looked bewildered following the
light of SCP 049 torch like a guiding
Beacon towards the edge of the perimeter
the foundation security all stood slack
jaot in amazement at what happened while
the plague doctor led the people and
urged the commander that they all needed
warmer clothing immediately he had done
it SCP 049 had cured the flesh that
hates in the coming months the
foundation soon found themselves very
busy everyone who had previously been
infected by a CP 610 needed to be
screened and examined just to make
absolutely sure there was no chance they
could mutate into a fleshy monstrosity
again but just like before with the
former SCP 008 zombies these people were
in perfect condition cured and healthier
than they had ever been by using his new
anomalous surgical skill and healing
power SCP 049 had returned the flesh
that hates victims back into human
beings it was starting to seem like
there was no disease no infection
anomalous or otherwise that he could not
cure the foundation began an effort to
rehouse the former SCP 610 infectees
given that most of them had spent years
as aggressive anomalous Abominations
almost every one of them had officially
been pronounced dead and couldn't just
go back to their old lives the SCP
Foundation gradually reintroduced them
into the world setting up new identities
and integrating them into new countries
SCP 049 even personally helped console
some of those that struggled with the
adjustment offering to give them therapy
to Aid in the process he was more than
just a plague doctor it seemed thanks to
the Clockworks SCP 04 9's good work
didn't stop with curing the flesh that
hates either as promised the foundation
allowed him to carry out about his new
found purpose whereas before he was
obsessed with eradicating what he called
the pestilence now the plague doctors
seem to be directing all his Focus to
curing the world as he put it and he
started with some of his fellow
anomalies the plague doctor started
experimenting with his new tools
concocting cures and serums of Plenty by
pulling whatever he needed from an
endless supply of equipment and
ingredients at his fingertips he
developed a cure for the condition that
caused Daniel McIntyre to become SCP
2800 cactus man his skin reverted back
to normal no longer sporting spines
while the plant-like parts of his DNA
once again became human SCP 049 even
offered a sympathetic ear to a lot of
Daniel's troubles giving him therapy
through a lot of his mental health
difficulties SCP 2102 was also one of
SCP 049 successful patience his
condition of rapidly overproducing new
skin tissue when injured quickly became
a thing of the the past then the plague
doctor turned his sights to The Wider
World working tirelessly to create new
vaccinations and treatments for diseases
that were once thought to be incurable
everything he made and had the
foundation distribute to those that
needed it was all 100% effective people
were healthier and happier than ever all
thanks to the plague doctor until they
weren't in attempting to eradicate
disease the world over a new strain of
illness emerged Ed SCP 049 took to
calling it a new pestilence and it was
nothing short of horrific it would have
been considered anomalous at one time
but it quickly became so widespread that
it couldn't be contained all the plague
doctors Advanced Medical Treatments had
encouraged this disease to mutate to
adapt against everything he could throw
at it it could infect any person at any
time and present itself with virtually
any symptoms it resisted drugs any form
of treatment and it it spread rapidly
eventually while trying to come up with
a way to protect people from the strain
of super bacteria this new pestilence
SCP 049 started to fall ill he had
caught it and even with his refinement
he was beginning to weaken the plague
doctor was dying and once he was gone
the whole world would soon follow as
more and more people caught the sickness
there was only one thing he could do a
way to leave someone behind to carry on
his work the foundation those that
weren't yet ill found SCP 049 he had
already passed but alongside his body
was something smooth and pearlescent an
egg and inside maybe a chance for the
world to be cured want an anomaly of
your own check out SCP swag.com for
highquality SCP merch somehow most
likely through some nefarious means a
fateful postcard has been sent to one of
the residents of the murky Mysterious
aranam Island living on this particular
Island was already a strange and scary
enough existence given the horrors the
inhabitants of anaram share their home
with but perhaps the only thing just as
horrible as life on that island was
being sent a postcard sure that doesn't
sound all that horrible postcards are
usually used to show a corner of the
world far away and extend well wishes
from friends or relatives on vacations
but ordinarily postcards don't depict a
photo of scp096 with the words wish he
was there scrawled on the other side
from its containment cell at the SCP
Foundation the shy guy instantly sensed
that somebody somewhere had seen a
picture of its face breaking down into
an enraged fit of homicidal insecurity
scp096 immediately broke from its
containment chamber and made a
CrossCountry beine heading straight for
arinum at anomalously accelerated speeds
little did the creature or the
foundation know that the shy guy was
being led straight into a trap and the
poor island resident who had received
the chilling postcard well they were
unlucky enough to be the bait while the
SCP Foundation started frantically
trying to track down where it had gone
the shy guy had already made its way to
a wooden cabin belonging to the
unfortunate postcard recipient a
emerging from the now emptied home once
the owner was no more scp096 would have
returned to his cell just as quickly as
he left that is if he wasn't the only
monstrous creature on the island a loud
and sudden noise caught the creatures
attention the sound of an old steam
train whistle it rang out once more from
somewhere off in the distance but there
was so much thick fog hanging in the air
around arinum that it was almost
impossible to see anything thing
especially with how dark it was the
second time the whistle sounded it was
closer but there was another sound to
and not the loud chugging of a steam
engine that you would expect it was an
erratic heavy thuing the noise of lots
of something drumming against the ground
causing the Earth itself to shutter legs
they were the steps of multiple huge
legs crawling across the surface of the
island heading straight towards as CP
096 a third piercing whistle rang out
even closer still this time the orange
glow of a light could be seen dulled by
the surrounding fog but getting brighter
and clearer as it came closer the light
was casting Shadows against the dark fog
long spinley shapes of spidery
appendages until before the shy gu's
eyes a creature of pure nightmares came
bursting out of the fog it was a
monstrous sight even to scp096
its body was the Red Front engine of an
oldfashioned steam train hoisted off the
ground by four pairs of enormous black
spinley spider-like legs that propelled
the Beast forwards at a terrifying speed
able to move without the limitations of
needing to follow a railroad track the
monster was barreling towards as scp096
with a twisted smile on its grotesque
face at the front the locomotive was its
circular face with its unnaturally white
eyes and a mouth that sported rows of
razor sharp teeth all covered in blood
this hellish Abomination a being that
was part steam engine and part giant
spider was the terror of arinum himself
the carnivorous Cho Chu Charles seeing
Charles racing towards them on its eight
spider legs would be enough to make
anyone freeze up and stop in their
tracks out of of sheer Terror and scp096
was compelled to do the same except the
terrifying train creatures pale eyes
were looking directly at the shy guy as
Charles sized the anomaly up as its next
meal he was looking at it and that meant
scp096 had to kill him the question was
how could it how could the skinny
spinley humanoid H to even fight
something like cho cho Charles he was
much bigger even more fearsome but as
quick as Charles could move on his
spidery legs he was not faster than
scp096 in the blink of an eye the shy
guy raced off shrieking and sobbing in
despair leaving Charles to continue
roaming his island territory in search
of other human inhabitants to terrorize
scp096 had retreated to some nearby
Woods quick enough to move out of
Charles's path somewhere it could hide
for now but the shy guy could feel a
familiar painful feeling almost pulling
him back towards Choo Chu Charles right
back into Harm's Way scp096 possessed an
inescapable compulsion to kill anyone
who looked at its face and that seemed
to include horrifying part train part
spider hybrids it was a fact of the Shy
Guy's very existence he had to go after
whoever looked at him and make them pay
in fact it took all the creatures Own
Strength not to instantly rush back over
to Charles to try scp096 knew that if it
did then there was little chance it
would survive coming face to train face
with the terror of arinir however while
it was watching Cho Choo Charles from a
safe distance seeing him crawl across
the landscape on his multiple legs that
SC scp096 noticed something it was
another light obscured by the fog but
this one was much higher up one could
almost mistake it for the moon if it
wasn't getting closer all the while
accompanied by the sound of woring
rotors well the shy guy had been evading
Choo Chu Charles the SCP Foundation had
been tirelessly trying to track down its
location and now they'd found their
runaway anomaly here on Aron niram
Island as the chopper carrying the
mobile task force Drew nearer the
tyrannical train turned and took notice
to scp096 the foundation's arrival could
have meant a way home and a way from the
spidery steam engine but to Charles the
approaching chopper meant only one thing
a new source of food Captain one of the
MTF troops aboard the chopper called
over his headset what is it do we have
eyes on scp096 the captain replied
before realizing what he'd said well not
eyes on because then it would have
jumped up onto the chopper and killed us
all I mean is there any sign of scp096
on the island negative sir although you
should probably see this the soldier
replied begrudgingly the captain
unbuckled himself from his seat and
snatched the foundation operatives
binoculars using them to look down at
arinum below it didn't take him long to
spot the massive multi-legged
monstrosity that was cho cho Charles who
had fallen still waiting for the chopper
to descend low enough for him to reach
good cravy what on Earth is that thing
the captain exclaimed before taking
another look through the binoculars is
that wait what is an instance of SCP
2086 doing out here SCP 2086 was an
Infamous anomalous species the
foundation had encountered before much
like Charles they were anthropod likee
creatures with multiple long legs that
protruded from a body resembling a
man-made mode of Transport however SCP
286s usually took on the appearance of
buses while in vehicle form sir I I
don't think that's an SCP 2086 the
lookout replied to me it looks more like
an instance of SCP 3023 impossible all
the way out here the captain retorted
we're nowhere near the region where the
anomaly occurs that could have scurried
its way from Germany and taken Nest here
sir the TR Trooper responded yet another
anomaly that Cho Chu Charles bore a
striking resemblance to SCP 3023 was a
rare phenomenon that was known to occur
at random but was limited to a specific
area of central Germany the effect of
this phenomenon caused ordinary everyday
inanimate objects of any shape or size
to suddenly turn into aggressive spiders
sporting eight legs That Grew From
whatever was affected by SCP 3023
perhaps Chuchu Charles was indeed an
instance of SCP 3023 or some distant
evolutionary offshoot of SCP 2086 it was
hard to say for sure the only thing for
sure was that Charles was a man-eating
Beast more so than an Insidious villain
and being so highly territorial he
considered the entire island of arinum
to be his natural habitat and his
hunting ground anything that arrived in
his vicinity was prey to the terrifying
train and his ravenous craving for human
flesh meant he was ready to attack the
descending SCP Foundation Chopper all
right let's go go go the MTF Captain
called to his troops signaling them to
start repelling out of the helicopter
and down to the island keep your
scramble goggles on Max we still need a
recapture 096 but first priority is
taking down this big ugly beast wearing
goggles specifically designed to distort
the shy guy from their view the team
began ABS selling out of the aircraft
but Cho Chu Charles was already waiting
for them rearing back on it four back
legs the nightmares train spider swiped
at the descending MTF operatives would
first seem like an instinctive
uncoordinated assault quickly became
precise and Relentless strikes as
Charles sliced through some of the
cables the MTF troops were using to
repel down their Lifeline cut the
Unlucky Foundation operatives plummeted
from midair right down towards where the
terror of Aaron neram was waiting for
them to fall a few of the mtfs made it
to the ground alive and immediately
began retaliating against Choo Cho
Charles the gunfire from their weapons
flickered all around the carnivorous
creature but their bullets could barely
chip the red paintwork on his steam
train body dashing towards his helpless
human prey on his many legs Charles
began to Feast then suddenly something
started pulling at one of his huge
spider legs pulling Charles back moments
before he had a chance to claim his
latest victim the captain of the
foundation's MTF it was scp096 having
zipped out of hiding and shrieking
loudly as it used all of its strength to
wrench one of Cho Chu Charles's multiple
limbs angered that it couldn't reach the
MTF Captain the part spider part train
hybrid stomped the leg that was being
pulled in a successful attempt to free
itself from the shy guys's grip but in
the same instant scp096 used its
anomalous speed to reappear in front of
the already angered locomotive monster
with his railroad rage about to reach
its Breaking Point Charles entered into
a Relentless Rampage making quick work
work of the leftover MTF troops before
setting his sight squarely on scp096 but
doing that was his biggest mistake now
Cho Chu Charles had seen the shy guy
twice and to the insecure anomaly that
meant Charles had to go traveling faster
than even the multi-legged monstrosity
could perceive scp096 began racing
towards chuch Chu Charles's many legs
the shy guy had realized that it didn't
stand a chance of dealing with the
terror of Aon niram the same way it
handled all the others that had seen its
face so instead it had settled on a new
approach specifically tailored to taking
down the spider legged steam engine one
by one scp096 started knocking Charles's
many legs out from underneath him
effectively tripping him up over and
over again the shy guy moved so quick
that the cumbersome Charles could barely
react in time having one leg after the
other knocked out from beneath him
causing him to Tumble to the ground
normally Choo Chu Charles was smart
enough to retreat if he encountered
something that could fight back if he
was injured badly enough the spider-like
creature would Scuttle out of Harm's Way
in order to heal his wounds but the rage
at being constantly tripped up by scp096
was distracting Charles from the shy
guys's true Ploy with every leg it
knocked out from underneath the spidery
steam train SCP 096 had been gradually
directing Charles towards a nearby Gorge
with a terrifying burst of anomalous
speed the shy guy caused Cho Chu Charles
to topple over sideways rolling over
himself until he landed upside down in
the bottom of the Rocky Gorge the
multi-legged locomotive Monster's
spindly legs flailed desperately as he
tried to reposition himself but with no
luck scp096 had managed what first
seemed to be impossible and beaten the
terror of Aon niram Chu Charles or for
now at least the Aftershock shuddered
through through the foundation emergency
alarms wailed as injured staff and
security helped each other out from
underneath Rubble that had fallen on
them as the building was shaken by the
Quake it had only lasted a few short
seconds but still managed to leave a
trail of Destruction in its wake while
the wounded were bandaged up anyone and
everyone who was still able to started
frantically checking the containment of
every anomaly on the site the foundation
could worry about the origin of the
Quake later first and foremost
they needed to assess the damage luckily
multiple rapid sweeps of the facility
revealed that there weren't all that
many highle threat anomalies whose
containment had been breached a few of
the safer ones were found cowering under
tables were buried under Fallen Rubble
in their quarters but for the most part
every anomaly was accounted for and none
had been provided with an opportunity to
escape and cause further Havoc at least
that's how things seemed at first it was
only when the chaos started to die down
and repair efforts were underway that
Personnel noticed an odd change
something was missing but nobody could
quite put their finger on exactly what
as a matter of fact most could pinpoint
exactly when they noticed this odd
feeling it had only begun after the
emergency alarms had been shut off there
was a sound that everyone working at the
foundation had gotten so used to that
they practically stopped hearing it or
at least they'd stopped noticing it it
was only now that the noise was gone its
absence no longer drowned out by blaring
alarms that staff realized it had always
been there everyone had just learned to
subconsciously tune it out crying the
low soft whimpering that could be heard
emanating from SCP 96's Containment
chamber it had stopped the cell within
had fallen silent and once someone at
the foundation made the right connection
and investigated they happened upon a
startling discovery
scp096 had vanished Panic immediately
engulfed the facility yet again the shy
guy could be anywhere and a search
effort to find it would only end in
deaths after all in order to find
something you have to look at it and
that was a fatal thing to do when scp096
was involved closer examination showed
no trace of the missing creature there
had been no reported incidents of
incursions with it anywhere in the world
every known photograph video recording
or other visual depiction of scp096 was
either securely stashed away or
destroyed completely by the foundation
there was no way it could have possibly
escaped and it was seemingly nowhere at
all but still the question remained
where in the world had the shy guy gone
to if it was still even in this world
from scp096 is perspective one moment
all had been normal the next it was lost
somewhere strange unfamiliar and above
all unsettling even to the shy guy
before the sudden Quake had hit it had
spent the day the same way it usually
occupied its time alternating between
aimlessly pacing the far wall of its
containment chamber and sitting in a
fetal position in the corner sobbing all
the while but then the room had started
shaking and in the blink of a deeply
sunken eye the shy guy found itself well
it had no idea where around it was a
large carpeted room open and sparse with
little occupying all the space the
wallpaper was a nauseating sickly shade
of yellow made all the more garish by
the rows of fluorescent lighting from
the ceiling above the entire Place
seemed to resemble an office space
although seemingly one that was in a
total state of disuse there was no
furniture not even one solitary
inanimate object to make the place seem
at least the tiniest bit closer to
normal little was scp096 aware it had
somehow been transported to a strange
and Terri terrible place the back rooms
unless someone remains wary and ever
Vigilant they can unknowingly slip their
way out of reality it can happen
anywhere all that a person needs to do
is be in the wrong place at the wrong
time and they will noclip into the back
rooms all around scp096 was the stench
of old wet carpet and a Labyrinth of
uninhabited rooms with the same drab
yellow walls the endless Buzz of the
fluorescent lights stretching out for
who knows how many square miles of empty
rooms in short the shy guy was trapped
in a Purgatory like nightmare however
there was at least one small Mercy for
scp096 as it wandered around its new
surroundings there was nobody else
around no other signs of life no SCP
Foundation No Ordinary human beings no
one who could see it here in the
solitary confinement of the back rooms
scp096 could not be per perceived and
yet this brought the self-conscious
creature very little in the way of
comfort despite being completely alone
there was an awful lingering feeling
that hung in the air like the smell of
the old carpet underfoot scp096 still
felt like it was being watched and yet
if someone or something really was
watching it wasn't triggering the Shy
Guy's usual rage State as it lurked
through the various rooms and corridors
the creature kept expecting to find
someone to look the in the eye directly
and get the same inescapable urge to
race towards its Observer and kill them
but it never came because there was
nobody else around at least for a little
while Adam Jenkins had been out riding
his bike when it happened pushing one
pedal around than the other he gradually
climbed higher up the slope of a hill
his house was down at the bottom of the
other side and Adam knew once he reached
the peak he could slip nice and easily
down the rest of the way as long as he
was careful not to to let the extra
momentum carry his bike too far and too
fast he just had to keep in control and
gently compress the brake if he needed
to he made the same Journey every day
nothing could go wrong sure enough Adam
reached the top of the hill and allowed
the bike to slowly tip ever so slightly
over the other side gravity started to
do the rest the wheels starting to spin
rapidly the pedals pistoning his legs as
he plummeted downwards it was one of the
few childlike Joys left in Adam's life
the those few brief seconds of the day
where he got to speed down the hill back
home with Reckless abandon he was
blissfully unaware that he wouldn't have
enough time to miss how much he enjoyed
it without warning a car came speeding
out from around a corner on the way down
the hill it was dark and the driver had
carelessly decided to leave their
headlights off so when Adam saw the
vehicle he only had a split second to
react he was still going too fast so if
he applied the brakes now his front
wheel would stop too suddenly and send
him flying forward over the handlebars
instead seconds before colliding with
the car's Hood Adam wrenched his bike's
handlebars and swerved around the car
but the added speed of going downhill
caused the entire bike to topple as it
turned so violently launching Adam off
and sending him hurdling towards a
nearby wall Adam could tell in the Split
Second after coming off his bike that he
was about to collide with the wall his
brain and body anticipated the impact
bracing him for the painful crash but it
never came instead of hitting the wall
Adam passed through it that may well
have spared him a devastating injury but
now a whole new problem now faced him
just like no clipping through a virtual
environment in a video game Adam had
passed directly out of reality right
into the back rooms the first few hours
were the worst shouting as loud as he
could for someone anyone to come and
find him each yell rapidly growing more
and more frantic as Adam rushed around
his haunting new surroundings the whole
place was unsettling just to be in it
gave off a hostile unwelcoming energy
that was impossible to ignore it was
only after an hour of trying to find a
way out that Adam realized he was well
and truly lost he'd strayed too far away
from his original point of entry and
just as he had the idea of trying to
make his way back to the world from the
same place he came in it was already too
late the back rooms at least on this
first level all looked the same no two
rooms were distinct enough for him to
figure out if this was somewhere he'd
been before or an entirely new area it
didn't take long for an overwhelming
sense of hopelessness to set in Adam had
quickly given up calling for help there
was no sign of anyone around that would
be able to help him until the shuffling
of footsteps came from nearby it was
such a noticeable break in the dull
unsettling quiet of the back rooms that
it made Adam's ears prick up the yellow
hued maze had been so void of life since
he had arrived so unnaturally empty that
he wasn't entirely sure he had made the
sound himself by his jacket brushing up
against the wall but no there was
definitely something here with him he
could hear it wandering nearby and it
had certainly hurt him too calling out
yet again with more caution in his tone
Adam Jenkins turned the next Corner met
with yet another dingy yellow Corridor
although unlike the others this one had
a key difference scp096 stood right in
the middle of it the split second that
Adam's eyes fell over the shy guy it was
already too late he barely had time to
process the side of the creature its
tall humanoid shape wiry thin and pale
skinned jaw hanging unnaturally wide in
fact scp096 dashed towards Adam so
quickly that he couldn't even finish his
startled scream meanwhile back at the
SCP Foundation efforts were still
underway to retrieve the shy guy
researchers were baffled that there was
not a single trace anywhere on the globe
of SCP 09 six's presence they had
quickly rolled out their usual method
for recalling the creature to
containment requisitioning one of
d-class personnel this individual was
instructed to stand in scp096 cell and
then was given a photograph of the
monster to look at knowing that the shy
guy would track down anyone that saw its
face even as a single tiny pixel in a
picture the foundation expected the
creature to Simply reappear in its
containment chamber to kill the d-class
they had used as bait but nothing
happened the d-class was able to look at
the photo of scp096 and survive it was
almost as if the creatures link to
reality was weakened wherever it was it
might still be aware someone had looked
at it but the shy guy was somehow being
blocked from traveling to its most
recent Observer having drawn a blank on
trying to determine SCP 96's whereabouts
the foundation eventually turned to SCP
343 for his input naturally the powerful
reality vender was reluctant as ever to
get involved involved the foundation
insisted knowing that SCP 343's
omniscience meant he would already be
aware of where they could find the
missing shyy he refused multiple times
admitting he did have the answer they
were looking for but not wishing to
divulge that information fine SCP 343
side coming to a compromise I can't tell
you exactly where 096 is but when I tell
you where to look for answers you'll
know async the researchers were stunned
into silence nobody in the foundation
had heard that name used in a long time
but SCP 343 was right they knew exactly
what it meant back in the 1980s async
was another shadowy organization that
had been investigating the existence of
a Lial space connected to reality a
place they had called the back rooms
Gathering up a mobile task force the SCP
Foundation dispatched its agents to a
site that had long since been abandoned
they'd kept a watchful eye over the
disused land lab keeping the public away
making sure nobody stumbled in by
accident and got trapped as the MTF
Commander gave the word the outdated 80s
technology was fired up and async great
achievement was reactivated they had
constructed a portal into the back rooms
moving information the MTF operatives
filed into the empty yellow space unsure
if they'd find scp096 alive or if it
would even want to come back meanwhile
in the back rooms level zero only the
Shy Guy remained having completely
annihilated Poor Unfortunate Adam he was
enjoying the Solitude once again knowing
that now nobody was here to see him
until one wrong step changed everything
he no clipped from Level zero to level
one where he would have a lot more
company the man sprinted through the
hallways of sight 01 as fast as he could
bullets whizzed over his shoulders as
Panic shouts went up all around him the
whole facility was bathed in red as
Security Alarms deafened his ears he had
to move fast had to get out of here
before it was too late a force smacked
him in the back so hard that he fell
onto his face skitting across the vinyl
floor planting both hands on the ground
and trying to push himself back up he
felt his right shoulder blade creaking
and bending against itself he'd been
shot enough times in his life to know
what a bullet shattered bone felt like
trying his best to ignore the pain
washing through his body he kept running
more bullets hit him in his torso his
shoulders his arms and his neck one even
caught the top of his skull slicing a
clear line through his hair but he kept
running the doors were slowly closing in
front of him as the foundation Personnel
swarmed the hallways all he had to do
was make it to those doors slide through
the Gap and he'd be free if only they
could understand if only all the agents
researchers and the overseer counsel
could make sense of what he was telling
them they would let him go through these
doors instead of trying to shoot him
down like a dog just 10 ft to go he was
nearly there when a bullet ripped
through his calf and sent him tumbling
to the ground again but this time before
he could get up a rain of bullets washed
through his body igniting a pain so
Fierce that he wished it could all just
be over but it never was the pile of
pitiful remains was wheeled back into a
containment cell with a door locked
behind it you would think the body lying
on the floor was some kind of roadkill
but it was in fact a man a man whose
body slowly and painfully over the
course of 4 months pushed every one of
the 247 bullets out of itself and got to
work stitching itself back together as
he lay there weeping on his own Andrea
Twain had been head hunted by the
foundation while she was still in
college sitting in a Harvard Library
she'd been hard at work on her thesis
pouring hour after hour into researching
jellyfish she was starting to see them
in her sleep and she was falling asleep
at her desk quite a lot fueled by energy
drinks and cups of coffee it was
starting to seem like the jelly fish
were floating all around her between the
bookshelves that's why when she was
approached by Foundation operatives
offering her a place studying the most
top secret entity on the planet she was
pretty sure it was all in her head but
then 6 months later and living in a
facility that she didn't even know the
location of it started to Dawn on her
the gravity of the task she had been
handed her research topic had been the
hydran turritopsis dorai a small
jellyfish with the power to reverse the
aging process dubbed the immortal
jellyfish she had been right on the
verge of cracking what was the creatur's
genetic makeup that made it able to
produce cells younger than those that
they were replacing a feat that could
cure all number of human diseases and
revolutionize medicine and society as we
know it but standing at the window in
sight 01 and looking through the glass
at SCP 001 Andrea realized that all of
her research had barely scratched the
surface of what was possible on the
other side of the window sat SCP 001 to
many this SCP was probably very
disappointing to look at it wasn't a
giant reptile they couldn't teleport
around the facility it didn't even have
any visible powers or really anything to
distinguish it from any of the other
researchers sitting on the other side of
the glass it looked entirely like a
regular human male it was housed in a
standard humanoid containment cell with
no added security features it was
sustained on a standard humanoid meal
program Three Square meals a day with
the correct number of calories nutrients
and vitamins if anything SCP 001
probably had a more balanced diet than
Andrea herself did some researchers have
questioned the need for feeding this SCP
it was Immortal totally unkillable and
resistant to aging it had been burned
alive drowned in acid and beaten to a
pulp and yet very slowly it would always
recover so why did they feed it if they
didn't it would get quite grumpy more
than anything in the world Andrea was
desperate to talk to it containment
procedures were very strict around this
SCP there would be no contact beyond the
delivery of meals no conversations no
sign language nothing it would sit by
itself alone in silence and three times
a day a meal would be placed in front of
it by a researcher who would promptly
leave the reason SCP 00 1 could predict
the future initial Research into this
SCP found that it had an uncanny ability
to describe events that had not yet
occurred despite having no exposure to
the outside world it could predict an
entire season of Major League Baseball
right down to the individual player
performances it foretold the fall of the
Berlin Wall the Chernobyl meltdown 9911
the crash of the housing market and
countless other events in 2004 a
careless researcher asked as scp1 won
what the weather was looking like SCP
001 proceeded in detail to describe
Hurricane Katrina from its formation
through to the humanitarian response and
the political Fallout a full year before
any of those events unfolded the
foundation has tried and failed to use
these predictions in order to prevent
tragedies from occurring but due to
ironic twists of Fate any attempts to
prevent these predictions from coming
true often wind up fulfilling them in
the case of chob agents who were
deployed into the Soviet Union to work
in the power plant itself wound up
making critical blunders that led to the
reactor's Meltdown if the foundation had
not gotten involved the accident would
have been averted that said taking a
passive approach does not appear to be
an effective countermeasure either it
seems that whatever SCP 001 predicts
that course of history becomes
inevitable how could you not want to
talk to such an entity as Andrea stood
at the glass watching it she knew she
had to hatch a plan the foundation may
not be able to prevent these tragedies
from occurring but surely they would
want to know what's going to happen they
were researchers after all and their job
was to discover information predicting
the future that was the most valuable
information of all but it went deeper
than that if anything the predictions of
the future were a byproduct in Andrea's
mind there was something suspicious
going on with this SCP something that
the foundation was trying its best to
keep under wraps she had seen it in the
classified documents files left out on
desks that should have been locked away
securely security and procedure had
grown LAX with the monotony of
containing this SCP in these files were
interview Snippets a chance for this SCP
to reveal who it truly was at the start
of the first interview Dr Lynch simply
pleasantly greeted SCP 001 he replied
your daughter will be hit by a bus
before her 7th birthday I can tell you
this specific day if you'd like the
interview session was paused as Dr Lynch
grew distressed and had to leave his
post to go and spend time with his
family the interview resumed under Dr
Goldstein who asked SCP 001 why he felt
the need to give such distressing
information to Dr Lynch he replied I
have told you people countless times
before you are not to refer to me as SCP
001 I am the founder of this
organization and you will address me as
such when Dr Goldstein questioned that
as eration SCP 001 replied you really
don't believe everything they have on
file do you address me as founder or I
will tell you about what your husband is
up to Dr Goldstein things collapsed very
quickly after that Andrea's plan started
as so many great plans due with her
sprinkling a chemical compound over one
of her colleagues Cheerios it was
nothing poisonous well at least not that
poisonous but it would put him out of
action for a few months long enough for
her to assume his position Andrea had
been next in line for a while to take
over the role of meal deliveries for SCP
001 and as her fellow researcher
violently vomited into a bucket in the
corner of their office she knew that her
time had come with the plastic tray in
her hands loaded with some kind of beige
slop and an apple she waited in the
doorway ready for the seals to hiss and
the door to slide slowly open for her
she stepped into the room trembling she
had expected the air in here to be stale
breathed and rebreathed for decades by
the same man but of course it had been
expertly filtered and purified by the
Foundation Systems the air in here was
as clean and balanced as it had been on
the other side of the glass the founder
looked up at her as she walked towards
him she would be a new face to him
something he hadn't seen for the prior 5
years his eyes dug into her showing no
surprise at all she suddenly realized
that of course he wouldn't be shocked to
see someone new he could see the future
he knew that she was coming suddenly
unsure of herself she wondered what else
he knew about her future about her most
closely guarded secrets about whether
her plan would work at all Andrea placed
the meal in front of him silently
knowing that the cameras and microphones
were all paying close attention to her
subtly as she could she nodded at SCP
001 turned around and left the room
Andrea's heart hammered as she sat back
down on the other side of the glass with
her colleagues her entire plan hinged on
one thing monotony all of the checks all
of the vigilance all the scrutiny that
had been poured into SCP 001 for decades
had to have Faded by now faded just
enough for the person watching the
security cameras not to notice one word
etched into the plastic tray as SCP 001
took its spoonful of food now SCP 001
launched from its chair and sprinted
towards the door in the corner of the
room before any of the other researchers
could react Andreas slammed a hand on
the the open door button there was a
hissing sound and the SCP was free from
its containment cell confused voices
filled the room yelling over one another
in utter confusion they had all been so
caught off guard that none of them had
paid attention to what had just happened
before they had time to put the pieces
together Andrea was out of the door
herself running down the corridor there
was just one door between her and the
SCP she ran over to key in the security
code to open the door and let the SCP
out but before she could even touch the
keypad a bullet caught her in the chest
and she collapsed to the ground wheezing
a scared security agent stared at her
wide-eyed what have you done he
exclaimed then both of them turned to
look at the locked door waiting Andrea
Twain had not wanted to let the SCP out
until she saw one specific line from an
interview tape SCP 001 referring to
itself as the founder explained in
patient detail how it was entirely
supportive of the foundation's goals
motivations and and actions it had no
intention of intervening with any of
their work it explained that all of
their ideas were in fact its own as it
was the one who had created the
foundation in the first place but there
was something coming a prediction that
SCP 001 refused to speak out loud under
any circumstances it had just one
request that it would repeat to every
interviewer for decades after decade
they had to free it so it could prevent
that event from happening it must be
allowed to construct a device otherwise
while it actually never explains that
part neither does it explain what this
device is and Point Blank refuses to
allow another to build this device in
its stead due to the unpredictability of
what would happen if SCP 001 was allowed
to construct this device the overseer
Council has Point Blank refused to
entertain the notion but Andrea just
couldn't shake it from her mind this SCP
was capable of accurately and precisely
predicting all number of future events
right down to the granular details no
matter how tragic and how dark yet there
was an unknown in its future it didn't
know whether it would be released or not
it had to beg for its freedom whatever
it needed this device to defeat was
clearly so powerful that it went beyond
SCP 001's capacity to predict and
understand it there was an event coming
that was so significant that it created
chaos and uncertainty in SCP 001's
perfect view of the future and there was
only one entity that Andrea trusted to
be powerful enough to counteract this
event and as she lay there dying in a
pool of her own blood she looked up
through the glass window in the door at
the entity she trusted and watched as it
keyed in the passcode to the door the
door slid open and the SCP took off
running along the hallway with her dying
breaths Andrea told the SCP the passcode
to the door that it had just opened
understanding the Brilliance of what had
just happened the SCP had been able to
open that door because it had seen the
future where she told it the password
and with that she smiled and laid her
head down on the hard floor except SCP
001 did not manage to escape it was
gunned down in the hallway with 247
bullets that brutalized its body and was
wheeled back into its containment cell
where it began the slow process of
healing for most of the research team
things went back to business as usual
albeit with slightly better security
but to the handful of researchers who
really thought about what had happened a
sense of unease settled on their
shoulders SCP 001 would have known
before it ran out of that cell and
attempted Andrea's plan that its Escape
was going to fail it would have known
decades prior to the exact positions of
the 247 bullets that pounded into its
body it would have known the Searing
Agony that it would have to endure for
months as its body slowly healed from
its failed escape attempt and yet it had
gone through through with it anyway what
set of events had been put into motion
when Andrea carved those three letters
into the plastic tray what greater
purpose was SCP 001 working towards and
was it now too late to stop it the
entire Foundation was in turmoil
researchers were getting into heated
fist fights with security officers who
in turn were retaliating in fits of
unbridled animalistic rage the facility
had erupted into such a frenzy with
chairs being hurled across Tes Chambers
and armories raided for weapons to
escalate the brawl into a far deadlier
incident tables were overturned and used
as cover as the foundation's own staff
turned on each other and before long an
allout War had erupted but this wasn't a
battle of one side versus another no
this was a wild and rampant freefor all
everyone was out to get everyone else
viewing their own colleagues as mortal
enemies and it was all thanks to Junior
the spawn of the shine guy only a month
before the foundation had been subject
to another bout of chaos although this
one was much more subdued than the
explosive battle that would later sweep
the facility everyone was a buzz
researchers ignored their work and some
security Personnel even abandoned their
posts to see what all the fuss was about
something was very wrong with scp096 the
creature was normally docile unless
directly observed it spent the majority
of its time just pacing around in its
containment chamber or staying hunched
over in a fetal position crying to
itself in fact it was so often sobbing
quietly and making all manner of
discontented noises that this became
known as its usual Behavior at first
almost nobody had noticed that something
was even a miss all seemed right with
the miserable monster that is until the
screaming started it was a loud
shrieking sound that pierced the eard
drums of whoever heard it then proceeded
to climb down their spine and bring a
chill to their bones making their blood
run icy cold and causing their skin to
be littered with Goosebumps the
screeching disturbing noise flooded out
of scp096 cell reverberating off of
every wall and echoing down every
Corridor until not one member of
foundation Personnel could ignore it it
was unlike anything they'd ever heard
from the creature before this Primal
howling seemed to put everyone who heard
it on edge not just because it was
unfamiliar but because everyone unky
seemed to know what the screams were
indicating pain perhaps even the worst
physical pain that scp096 had ever felt
what if the shy guy was dying something
had to be done but therein lay a hurdle
to clear first how could the foundation
help even offer medical assistance if
needed to a creature they couldn't even
safely look at what options are there
for even getting somebody close enough
to examine the shy guy without it
killing them they were limited but a
crowd of the SCP foundation's best and
brightest researchers had already
congregated outside the containment
chamber housing 096 after they heard its
screams surely between them they could
come up with an idea hearing the shy guy
continuing to Howl in agony one
researcher came forward and made a
suggestion there was a device another
Foundation researcher had developed code
named scramble resembling standard issue
night vision goggles one Dr Dan had
created these scramble goggles to
identify 0 96's face and digitally alter
it so that the wearer was unable to see
its face essentially it edited out the
shy guy's face in real time so that its
homicidal rage State couldn't be
activated the use of Dr Dan's scramble
goggles had previously led to a
catastrophic incident that claimed the
lives of mobile task force to 1 also
known as Big Brother The Scrambled
devices allowed the wearer's brain to
receive a single nanc of scp096
unscrambled scambled before the image
was altered by the goggles so needless
to say since time was running out to
help the creature and there were no
other viable options for doing so the
scramble goggles would need some serious
refinement and fast working as quickly
as they could they gathered gaggle of
researchers requisitioned an old pair of
scrambled goggles and started trying to
improve them tinkering equipment
Specialists put their heads together
with computer science Engineers as they
coded like crazy all underscored by the
continued screen of scp096
then without warning or even a hint of
what had happened inside the cell the
screaming suddenly stopped everyone
outside the containment chamber stopped
for a second falling deathly silent the
goggles were almost ready but were they
too late to save the shy guy the
security Personnel who had also gathered
in response to the sound all Drew straws
with the officer pulling the shortest
being the one tasked with venturing into
the containment chamber he was handed
the goggles and instructed that that
they would blur his version entirely for
a few seconds while the scramble
software had a chance to work then once
the device had double triple and
quadruple checked the results the
goggles would activate fully and in
theory worked the way Dr Dan had
originally intended although the track
record of the scramble project meant
that the officer was hardly reassured as
he entered the dark dingy containment
chamber he couldn't see a thing ahead of
him his vision totally obscured as the
goggles started running the newly
updated version version of the scramble
software they were untested so naturally
the security officer's nerves were at
Peak levels worried the device might
fail and any second his eyes would be
greeted by the face of scp096 he could
tell the creature was still alive there
was a low sound of panting breaths
coming from the far corner of the
chamber indicating that it hadn't
perished although it might have been
injured a sudden beep from the scramble
goggles startled the officer the device
had made its checks and was ready to
activate however an unexpected message
blinked on the heads up display that
read warning multiple subjects detected
luckily enough when the goggles
activated the officer was relieved to
see they had worked SCP 96's face was a
grainy pixelated mess the creatur showed
little noticeable sign of any injuries
too and just seemed to be gently rocking
itself in the corner but quickly the
reason and perhaps even the cause of SCP
96's earlier scream soon became obvious
though no body had entered the
containment cell before the security
officer it seemed the shy guy wasn't
alone standing at about a third of
scp096 is considerable height was
another shy guy or at least another
version of a creature almost identical
save for being shorter it wobbled on its
elongated legs like it wasn't quite used
to standing upright it kept both arms
outstretched towards s scp096 almost as
though it was reaching out for a hug but
the shy guy stayed in the corner cing
away from the other creature through his
scramble goggles the security officer
looked on in disbelief at the scene
before him somehow completely
unpredictably scp096 had spawned an
offspring it had had a baby there was a
general air of disbelief among the
assembled staff outside the containment
chamber after the security officer had
relayed what had happened most were
quick to write it off as an
impossibility they'd studied scp096 for
a long time and it had been the only
anomaly known to the foundation matching
its own very particular description
there had been no other cited in the
wild it didn't seem to be part of a
species as far as anyone knew but other
researchers refuted this claim given
scp096 his ability to travel at
anomalous speeds and kill those that
looked at it it stood to reason there
could be others maybe the foundation
wasn't aware of a whole species of shy
guys because anyone who'd ever seen one
didn't live long enough to report report
it then someone mentioned that it wasn't
entirely unprecedented for anomalies to
have Offspring either a long while
before SCP 049 the infamous beak Mass
plague doctor had laid an egg which had
hatched into SCP
049-j a smaller version of himself
composed of moss and wads of tissue
trying to apply logical understanding to
each and every anomaly was a paradoxical
exercise in futility all anomalies had
their own rules even rules the
foundation had never observed before
after a great deal of deliberation and
additional improvements of the scramble
technology a research team was sent into
the containment chamber to retrieve SCP
96's progyny the parent creature was
still shying away from its creation
perhaps because it didn't want to raise
it in the way that meant the child
inherited its deadly sense of
self-consciousness then again maybe the
shy guy was just afraid of what it had
Unleashed on an unsuspecting Foundation
initial testing with The Offspring
creature revealed it was perfectly
healthy and seemingly very much unlike
its predecessor until any official SCP
Foundation designation number could be
assigned the team examining it took to
calling it scp096
Jr or shortened to Simply junior junior
regarded the foundation scientists with
curiosity intrigued by them as well as
their surroundings picking up medical
instruments before very carefully
placing them back where it found them
treating every it touched like they had
been made of the finest most delicate
glass one of the researchers likened its
movements to that of a lemur or other
similar primates but with the reserved
timid and docile nature of a well
domesticated pet that was at first
naturally the SCP Foundation being the
organization that it is it quickly
became an interest in whether Junior
displayed the same anomalous traits as
scp096 call it curiosity or caution they
wanted to know if it would react the
same way when observed without the
protection of scramble goggles so a test
was devised seating a member of declass
Personnel in the same room as Junior and
tasked only with looking at the shy guys
spawn everyone gathered with baited
breath the research team watching from
an observation desk all of them wearing
scramble goggles to blur Junior's face
as a blindfolded d-class was brought in
and stood opposite of Junior all of them
expected that the test would unfold in a
particular way which made it all the
more surprising when as the DCL class's
blindfold was removed nothing happened
Junior regarded the convict with the
same general curiosity as it had for
everyone else but beyond that showed no
change in Behavior no wild crying no
murderous rage State nothing are we sure
this is actually the shy guys kid one of
the researchers choked with the test
concluded and then repeated a few extra
times for good measure Junior was deemed
a safe class anomaly much like SCP 999
or Josie the half cat it was decided
that Junior be allowed to wander freely
around the facility while initially a
little unnerving to some staff when they
first saw him without goggles people
quickly warned to Junior he was like a
small monkey from a Safar Park although
with the added benefit of not stealing
anyone's iPhone or wallet but at least
until shortly after around nearly a
month had passed since Junior's birth
and since then an odd change had been
noted in SCP 096 the shy guys seemed
calmer more at ease and far less anxious
what's more researchers discovered that
for the first time ever he could be
observed however before they could
investigate further all hell broke loose
it started in the holding cells where
DCL classes were housed initially
written off as fights between inmates
that got a little too out of hand but
soon the foundation's own Personnel
started to violently attack each other
it was sparked at random a state of
animalistic rage that was focused on
their fellow staff members the people
they worked with the people who saw them
every day and it didn't stop those
working at the facility were seemingly
possessed by an inescapable urge to harm
those around them as if punishing each
other for just looking at them by the
time a mobile task force was ordered to
step in and diffuse the situation the
scene they arrived to was one of utter
chaos further examination uncovered that
those who had seen Junior's face had
been exposed to an anomalous effect
looking at the creature gave the
Observer the same rageful reaction to
being observed as scp096 they were
compelled to kill anyone who saw them
however most insidiously this didn't
seem to take effect instantly in fact
those affected only entered their
Collective rage state after everyone in
the facility had interacted with Junior
at least once almost like it had been
waiting to infect everyone while the
remainder of the foundation mopped up
the aftermath of the incident some
theorized that SC scp096 had somehow
expelled all its self-consciousness all
of its negative traits into its progyny
this was supposedly why the shy guy seem
so much calmer so much so that it could
even be observed whether Junior simply
couldn't contain all scp-096's
negativity or intentionally spread it to
everyone else around it it is unknown
the only solution to get things back to
normal was to put the shy guys
self-consciousness back to where it came
from Norse mythology tells the story of
yorong Gand a Great Serpent so long that
it wraps itself the entire way around
midgard and bites its own tail Legend
says that when yorong Gund unclasps its
jaws and starts to unfurl it will signal
the beginning of Ragnarok the
destruction of the world and that was
about as much information as the
foundation gave to agent neelen when
they assigned him to his watch Duty in
Greenland in the Frozen Tundra all day
every day he had been equipped with a
sniper rifle thermal goggles and put up
high in a watchtower if he saw anyone
anyone he had to shoot on site no
questions asked whether it was his
squadmates the brigadier general or even
his own mother if anyone walked across
the barren stretch of ice ahead of him
he was to shoot them dead under no
circumstances was anyone allowed to
enter that cave the fate of the world
could depend on it but it was cold and
the days were long for months he'd been
sitting there by himself without seeing
a single soul walk across the glacier
that's why it took him so long to spy
the figure stumbling across the ice half
a kilometer away but the person didn't
look any clearer when agent neelon took
a look through his thermal binoculars
barely registering as much warmer than
the snow around him the man stumbled
forward seemingly unaware of the world
around him could this be the start of
the Swan Song of the world is this what
he had been warned about without a
moment's hesitation agent neelen
snatched up the sniper rifle and readied
his sights on the man somewhere buried
deep beneath the Greenland ice is one of
the most dangerous scps that the
foundation has ever come across to say
that SCP 722s Reawakening could spell
the destruction of human civilization is
no Idol concern classified as a ker
level SCP SCP 722 has been nicknamed
yorong Gund after the Norse myth
researchers speculate that the
creature's existence could in some way
be linked to the early origins of the
story of the Norse creature 722 was
brought to the foundation's attention
relatively recently environmental
activist group Greenpeace was shooting a
documentary on the effects of global
warming on glaciers in Greenland a small
crew including a director producer three
camera operators and a sound recordist
headed out to get some close-up footage
from amongst the glaciers walking from
ice sheet to ice sheet they noticed
several rounded entrances to what looked
like like deep Ice Caves surmising that
these openings were only accessible to
them because of the melting Glacier Ice
the crew climbed down into the caves to
get some neverbe seen footage some of
the footage of their exploration has
been recovered since and in the
background of several shots as they are
adjusting exposure and pulling Focus you
can hear the producer and director
theorizing about where these caves have
come from they initially seem to think
that the caves are Millennia old
preserved by Sub-Zero temperatures but
soon they come across several markings
on the walls ancient hieroglyphs and
symbols none of the crew were language
experts and so in the footage you can
hear them struggling to identify which
people group would have carved those
into the ice walls in the decades since
language experts from around the world
have studied these markings on those
walls and have still been unable to
identify any discernable links to any
known human script most agree that it
does seem to predate the settlement of
the island by Eric the Red at the start
of the 11th century during this period
it is believed that there were no human
settlements on the island so the origins
of this script remain unknown as the
footage goes on you may start to notice
something that the Green Piece crew does
not one of the ice walls is no longer a
wall at all it looks like a rock in some
of the footage but whenever a flashlight
Shines on its surface you can see a
pattern to it scales then an opening at
the far side of the tunnel the crew
emerges into an enormous Cavern
estimated to be upwards of 200 m in
height and several times wider even
their powerful flashlights struggle to
cut through the darkness inside that's
the point that the sound recorders
notices the scales running alongside
them as the camera pans you see that
they have been walking alongside a tail
several times taller than them a tail
that snakes its way through the darkness
of the cavern to meet a hulking mass at
the other side shrouded in darkness that
is where the footage cuts off those
green Green Peace filmmakers were next
seen in a local town that evening none
of them had the chance to extol the
wonders of what they'd encountered that
day as they were all sick a couple went
straight to bed in their lodgings
complaining of intense headaches and
exhaustion others tried to check
themselves into the ER but never made it
each of the crew died of different
causes necrosis of the skin internal
bleeding kidney failure by 9 p.m. that
day all of them were dead fortunately
there just so happened to be a low-level
Foundation agent staying in the same
guest house as them who heard the
commotion within 2 days a perimeter was
established within 2 years the
foundation gained the bulk of knowledge
of this SCP that they rely on to this
day it is unknown exactly how large as
CP 722 actually is a hulking serpent
half buried in ice much of its body
cannot be observed it sleeps coiled up
in the middle of the cavern that the
filmmakers happen to cross some of its
body is buried beneath fallen in parts
of the caves others frozen into the
ground around it however based on what
can be observed of this SCP it is
estimated to be in the ranges of 8 to 12
km from head to tail fortunately for
just about everyone including you this
SCP appears to be dormant and no time
since its Discovery has this SCP been
observed to move make a sound or
otherwise indicate Consciousness sensors
are installed in the chamber to monitor
its life functions and study its heart
rate temperature brain activity and more
one concern to the foundation is that
since its Discovery 722 has had a 9%
uptick in neural activity researchers
hope that this is just a natural part of
the sleep cycle and that it will return
to a deeper Slumber soon that is the
hope at least so what makes this SCP so
dangerous then if it's sound asleep well
let's go back to agent neelon staring
through the scope of his rifle the
barrel kicked back a puff of warm smoke
there and gone in cold air he watched
just long enough to confirm the kill
before radioing back to command what he
had observed within an hour the cleanup
crew arrived riding on snowmobiles they
waited at a distance for an hour before
approaching the body rather
unceremoniously they wrapped it up in a
black plastic bag strapped it to the
back of their snowmobile and took it
away for cremation neelen just sat there
in his Watchtower the whole time
observing it all the person looked sick
and not the kind of sick that You' get
from spending too much time out there on
the ice their skin had gone rotten like
they had gang greine or leprosy it
wasn't just your usual frostbite most
concerning they'd been wearing a
jumpsuit standard issue for d-class
personnel only a vial held in their cold
dead fingers was any kind of clue for
neelen as to what had been going on in
that cave but that was as close as the
agent ever came to understanding the
mysteries of SCP 722 the vial however
however was in many ways all he needed
to know that is because contained in
that vial was a sample of the liquid
secreted by
722 it is a liquid that the Greenpeace
crew came into close contact with when
they found the creature and it's a
liquid that promises and denies great
power and great risk to the foundation
any and all attempts to study this
liquid in any meaningful sense have
failed anyone who comes into contact
with it will immediately suffer acute
sickness interestingly however there
seems to be little consistency as to how
this sickness manifests itself some
develop a number of cancerous cells
whilst others lose cognitive function
due to brain swelling symptoms seem to
vary from person to person naturally
this makes studying the substance very
difficult hazardous material suits have
been deployed for researchers attempting
to study it but have all failed despite
being otherwise effective against
chemical biological and radioactive
threats how the substance is able to
infect them is is unknown sadly a good
number of scientists had to die to make
this discovery another route of study is
to take the substance out of the cave
and observe it under laboratory
conditions this was what agent neelon
observed as he shot and killed the
d-class Personnel emerging from the Cave
the d-class had been sent in to retrieve
the vial of the substance for external
study while a safe and direct route of
entry and exit had been planned for the
man to take he became critically ill
whilst in contact with 722 and developed
an aggressive fever no longer coherent
over the radio he dropped out of signal
wandering through the tunnels for 2
hours until emerging out of an exit high
up on the glacier two agents with higher
security clearance were dispatched to
deal with the body the reason for their
waight was for their own safety 722s
toxin appears to denature with time away
from its source causing it to weaken in
potency if they had approached
immediately they may have well suffered
similar Fates to the d-class they
survived but the sample was ruined all
subsequent attempts have also been met
with failure it seems almost impossible
to capture a clean sample and transport
it any kind of distance with this toxin
the foundation would have possession of
an immense biological weapon akin to the
discovery of the atom bomb but as of
right now all it's good for is killing
d-class Personnel initially the
foundation believed the fluid to be a
defense mechanism for the SCP something
to protect it in its deep sleep but the
more time is spent observing it the more
time this perception is Shifting SCP
722s toxin appears instead to be a
weapon as such the containment of this
creature is of Paramount importance
there are eight known access points into
the tunnel Network that would Grant
access to SCP 722 each of them has been
sealed with reinforced gates with
additional layers of soundproofing at
regular 4-Hour intervals nitrogen gas
cooled to a near liquid state is to be
pumped through these doors without fail
it is believed that the creature is a
form of Proto reptile and so is
theoretically coldblooded its internal
temperature is dictated by its
surroundings therefore by keeping a cool
average temperature in these caves it is
thought that this scp's Slumber can be
prolonged how long is unclear with
Rising global temperatures year after
year the threat that the Green Peace
activists were proclaiming is very real
just perhaps not quite in the way they'd
envisioned Not only would there be an
increase in natural disasters and a
decrease in biodiversity there would
also be a 12 km snake roaming around the
planet killing anyone in its path not
ideal as such the foundation has also
planted a number of Highly skilled
individuals in prominent environmental
positions in the hopes of turning the
tide of global warming sooner should the
ice in that cave system warm by even a
couple of degrees who knows what kind of
Spike they might see on the neural
monitors this SC SCP naturally is buried
deep beneath layers and layers of
security clearances too only in
exceptional circumstances and for Vital
maintenance is anyone allowed to
approach this SCP a minimum of two level
three clearance agents are required to
sign off on any such Works in recent
years a new Brigadier General took
charge of the containment operations of
SCP 722 after his predecessor was
stripped of his duties overly zealous
experiments and increasingly desperate
attempts to harvest or syn ized the 722
toxin saw an alarming uptick in neural
activity over 40 d-class Personnel were
processed and disposed of within a 2 we
period in an attempt to assemble a micro
laboratory within the main chamber
itself this project failed and the
noises of construction threatened the
peace that had so long been maintained
beneath the glacier the new Brigadier
General is taking no such risks
enforcing a zero tolerance policy on
anyone approaching site 103 unless
suitably cleared a number of hikers have
sadly had to be killed this way but the
foundation believes it to be a necessary
sacrifice to keep the peace it is quite
easy to find a convincing backstory for
their untimely deaths and the lack of
bodies to bury just another person to
get lost and fall down a crack in the
glacier warning stories that are shared
and planted in local towns and on the
internet the only threat to this current
piece is a new Avenue of inquiry that
researchers have stumbled across a link
to a group of animals found halfway
around the world monitor lizards of the
genus varanus seem to share a similar
set of traits to SCP 722 namely the
nature of their toxins you may be
familiar with the bite of a kodo dragon
while the initial wound sure does hurt
the real damage comes in the following
hours and days as necrosis sets in from
the toxins in its mouth could these
creatures share a common ancestor could
722 be the common ancestor as of right
now it is just a hunch but it's one that
has taken root amongst the research
staff in order to find out more though
they need samples tissue samples taken
straight from the SCP itself the only
way to do back is to go back into the
caves and start cutting if a bit of
construction noise was enough to raise
brain activity by 9% taking a hunk of
Flesh could prove a whole lot more
dangerous not least for the Personnel
involved who will all have to sacrifice
their lives the potential benefits could
be huge a way to study fatal diseases in
a new light perhaps finding a way to
reverse engineer cures to some of the
deadliest conditions on the planet or
perhaps the missing ingredient to
synthesizing the most powerful
biological weapon in human history maybe
worst of all it could all trigger The
Reawakening do you remember how the
story of yorong gundur ends with a
prediction that when the Great Serpent
on coils the end of the world Ragnarok
itself will arrive but that's just an
old fairy tale right Dr Bry Dr cleff and
Dr gears all sat around a conference
table the monitor beside them giving a
direct encrypted video link to 05- one
the most senior member of the legendary
05 Council only one topic was on the
roster today the inherent nature of one
of the most problematic anomalies SCP
682 the hardto destroy reptile there
were certain facts that were easy to
ascertain about 682 like the fact that
its default State appears to be vaguely
reptilian the fact that it's highly
aggressive and the fact that it is
seemingly impossible to kill the rest it
seems is still largely shrouded in
mystery how can we expect to terminate
this creature if we don't fully resolve
to understand it Dr gears offered it
appears that all of our efforts so far
have amounted to firing a gun in the
dark and hoping for the best do you have
any idea how much money we've blown on
the termination efforts so far believe
me the numbers would shock you Dr brigh
chimed in with as the only one in this
room who's literally been inside this
Monster's head referring to the incident
where 682 was made to ingest Dr Bright's
Medallion in hopes of letting the
doctor's Consciousness take over the
Beast which didn't work I think I speak
to a degree of authority when I say I'm
not sure if we'd have any luck actually
understanding it it's like asking a
volcano how it feels about erupting Dr
cleff thoughts from the matter were
predictable okay look I may not have
mind melded with this Abomination like
Jack but I've got du working eyes and a
decent brain attached to them that's all
I need to tell you our solution here is
obvious more Firepower we've been going
easy on this thing so far letting it
face different anomalies one at a time
not going at it with any truly heavy
weaponry and for some stupid reason
ruling out nuclear armaments that had
everyone around the room rolling their
eyes there he goes with nukes again Dr
Bri said nukes nukes nukes if you love
nukes so much why don't you marry them
huh cleff clef grumbled in frustration
why did everyone around here gets so
risk adverse feart never won fair mine
or killed giant ugly lizards why should
we treat a nuke like it's such a dirty
word Dr gears side if the break room
coffee machine malfunction you'd tell us
to make sure the nuclear response option
stays on the table cff cluff banged his
hand on the table because I believe in
getting results no matter what enough
05- one barked silencing the room
everyone turned to the Monitor and gave
their undivided attention as their
Superior spoke I can staunchly confirm
that we will not be pursuing a nuclear
option for 682 under any
circumstances I do not intend on
creating a Godzilla we need to fight
gears I think you're on to something
we've done all we can to analyze SCP 682
Through The Eyes of scientific
empiricist perhaps we need to look at it
Through The Eyes of its fellow anomalies
the ones that aren't completely insane
anyway make it happen gentlemen chop
chop and so they did all three of the
incredibly different doctors did see the
wisdom in 05- one's new Theory perhaps
they could gain a holistic understanding
of 682 by collating knowledge gained
from other anomalies and through this
knowledge they might also be able to
find a weakness that somehow slipped by
unnoticed right now 682 was like an
impenetrable locked door but even the
most durable locked door can be defeated
with the right key there were certain
anomalous perspectives on SCP 682 that
they already had take for example that
of SCP 343 the kind reality warper also
known as God when confronted with SCP
682 during a termination attempt the two
of them seemed patently unaware of each
other's presence when quizzed on the
subject 343 claimed that 682 wasn't one
of his is perhaps implying some kind of
extradimensional origin it also lends
Credence to the popular theory that 682
was one of the children of the Scarlet
King though for now that would still
remain nothing more than a theory not
something they could really act upon
this was why each of the three
researchers following the orders from
05- one began canvasing reactions from
other intelligent anomalies in hopes of
getting a useful kernel of information
from a fresh new angle Dr brigh who has
frankly seen far too many movies thought
of himself as Clarice Starling
interviewing a whole collection of
Hannibal lectors in hopes of gaining a
unique Insight that would help him catch
the killer when he shared this thought
with Dr cleff and Dr gears gears told
brigh that he didn't watch movies and
cleff called brigh a nerd after the
proper safety precautions were put in to
make sure that the two never actually
came into physical or mental contact Dr
cleff had SCP 035 the DV diabolical
possessive mask attached to a mannequin
host body and brought in to observe as
CP 682 in a sealed chamber clef asked
the possessive mask to relay any
thoughts he had while looking at the
Beast admittedly Dr klef felt a little
unnerved by how gleeful The Mask looked
while watching the hard to destroy
reptile clambering around in its tank oh
yes yes the possessive mask said its
words like cyanide in the ears what a
truly marvelous creature so large so
powerful so violent oh I can feel the
hatred radiating off of it from here you
know the hateful ones are often the
easiest to manipulate there's so much
they'll do for power so much they'll
sign away while their malice blinds them
oh delightful such a wonderful thought I
don't suppose you'd let him wear me
would you Dr cleff shook his head not on
your life grape sadly it didn't seem as
though any new insights had really been
gained here hopefully Dr gears would
have a little more luck with his project
Dr gears had decided to take a more
measured approach unsurprising given
this is Dr gears were talking about and
went for an intelligent anomaly who
probably wasn't harboring some evil
ulterior motive SCP 507 The Reluctant
Dimension Hopper two things highly
benefited Dr gears in this regard
firstly the reluctant Dimension Hopper
had gotten around and seen more things
than pretty much any other Mortal being
in existence secondly SCP 07 had certain
aspirations namely to become an SCP
Foundation researcher where he could be
accepted and make a profession out of
his interest in the Supernatural gears
could leverage this to gain cooperation
when scp-507 was brought into to observe
682 gears noticed a certain flicker of
recognition in the dimension Hopper's
eyes before the man opened his mouth and
said oh God not another one of those
things gears immediately fired back
another one you say SCP 57 nodded yeah
during one of my jumps I was in this big
weird landscape covered in freaky
looking rocks there were a whole bunch
of these guys there like a herd or a
pack or something as soon as they saw me
they started chasing me it was honestly
pretty tense for a second there I didn't
even know if I'd make it out alive Dr
gears nodded and continued taking notes
do you have any further observations
from your time seeing these creatures in
another dimension SCP 507 shook his head
presumably disappointed that he couldn't
offer more thank you that'll be all then
507 Dr gears said and of course that
left one more the Maverick the Joker in
the pack Dr Jack brigh the man from whom
you can only ever really expect the
unexpected he decided to take the middle
ground between the offerings of Dr gears
and Dr clef SCP 049 the plague doctor
the mysterious being who can kill with a
touch but as aspirations to heal Dr Bry
was extremely interested in seeing what
he had to say about the nasty reptile
that same day the plague doctor was
feeling a little irritated to say the
least he'd been conducting some
extremely important Research into the
pestilence on a cow carcass when
suddenly an order from the top deemed he
would no longer have access to animal
subjects lavender had been pumped into
his cell to pacify him while five
heavily armored guards entered and
dragged out his his subjects it was
cruel it was inhumane it was
anti-science first they'd taken away his
live Human subjects then they'd taken
away his dead human subjects followed by
his live animal subjects if he wasn't
even allowed to perform his vital
research on animal carcasses now then
what hopes did he have of making
progress well out there in the world
every single day the pestilence spreads
further who even knows what form it has
taken now after all diseases shift and
mutate with the times and the whole
world was a petri dish out there as the
plague doctor was lost in his musings Dr
brigh approached and wrapped his
knuckles on the plexiglass of his
containment chamber leave me be doctor
the plague doctor sighed haven't you and
your compatriots already taken enough
from me I'm not here to take doctor I'm
here to give Dr brigh said I know we can
be a little harsh in our measur
sometimes doc but we're cold not cruel
if you play ball with us you'll find we
can be very amicable to the tune of say
getting your live animal research
privileges back there was a moment of
silence before the plague doctor rose up
and walked over to the divider between
himself and Dr brigh he cocked his head
slightly as though taking in Dr Brit's
measure what would you have me do in the
return doctor the plague doctor asked Dr
brigh smiled there's just something I
want you to look at with the assistance
of a few security officers the plague
doctor was moved over to an observation
chamber joining on to a larger more
secure ch chamber the plague doctor sat
on a plush chair staring through a
one-way mirror into the larger chamber
Dr brigh turned on a Dictaphone hoping
to record any interesting observations
the plague doctor came out with what
prel am I supposed to be looking at Dr
bright he asked oh they're bringing him
in now won't be a moment Dr brgh said a
large door in the larger chamber opened
and several members of personnel dragged
in a tied up incapacitated SCP 682
looking like it was still recovering
from heavy injuries immediately SCP 049
seemed to tense up Dr brgh was
fascinated watching the plague doctor's
previously calm demeanor suddenly become
marred by clearly evident worry what was
he thinking would it be a useful Insight
the silence continued as the plague
doctor seemed to carefully observe the
immobilized Beast for a moment or two Dr
Bri even noticed the plague doctor's
hands shaking slightly moments later the
doctor cleared his throat and said the
pestilence never have I seen it so
malignant come again doc Dr brde asked
this thing it is sick dreadfully sick it
is a Bastion of disease a harbinger of
plague unlike anything I've ever seen
before how long have you had this filthy
thing within your walls doctor how many
people have made contact with it quickly
please I must know for the safety of all
of you as the plague doctor became
increasingly agitated Dr briy became a
mix of deeply concerned and Incredibly
curious sure as cp's 49 tended to go off
about a lot of things allegedly being
infected with the pestilence but this is
different there is genuine fear shaking
in the plague doctor's voice I I feel
unwell doctor the plague doctor said
rising shakily to his feet please escort
me back to my Chambers I simply cannot
deal with such a case without proper
preparations it would be too dangerous
Dr Wright ordered the security Personnel
to make the plague doctor's desire a
reality he would be escorted back to his
chamber be given a lavender supplement
as well as a meal of beef and hard
cheese his favorite to help him
recuperate from his shock but all
throughout this process Dr brigh had
latched on to one fragment of the
doctor's mutterings I simply cannot deal
with such a case without proper
preparations did that mean with the
proper preparations SCP 049 could deal
with SCP 682 and as with most of 04 9's
patients did deal mean kill if so then
this this project was really about to
Bear some impressive fruit after giving
the plague doctor a few days to get
himself reoriented Dr brgh returned with
another offer one he wasn't even sure he
had the authorization to make but if his
plan worked out he was sure he could
swing it he offered the plague doctor
the chance to work with human subjects
again if he could first successfully
treat SCP
682 it would certainly be an undertaking
as DP 049 said trying to hide his clear
discomfort but for the sake of science I
must accept over the next few days the
preparations were drafted up and the
plague doctor was given any equipment or
resources he requested for the task of
curing SCP 682 then when the day came
SCP 682 was tied up and sedated once
again and dragged into a large cross
testing chamber where Dr Wright the
plague doctor and several members of
security Personnel were waiting it was
now or never would the doctor be able to
do it for what it's worth I Believe In
You doc Dr Brite said giving a tentative
thumbs up the plague doctor didn't
return the thumbs up he was too busy
trying to stop himself from visibly
shaking in the face of this giant
diseased monstrosity would he have any
hope of treating such a beast he exhaled
and approached as with all of his
patience his first step would be to lay
a hand on the monster which normally
rendered it peaceful and still the
plague doctor slowly walked over his
hand hand extended feeling the prickles
of fear all over his body he could do
this he could do this but as he
approached s SCP 682 had somehow freed
one of its arms and swung for SCP 049
with its vicious claws 049 screamed and
stumbled back hitting the ground and
crawling away in the opposite direction
practically wheezing with Terror he
eventually gathered himself up in the
corner and curled into a ball shaking Dr
brigh breathed a sigh of disappointment
it seemed this entire Venture had been a
wash H take 049 back to his cell Dr
brigh said resigned we're all done here
for everyone else it was just another
failed cross test quickly forgotten with
all the others for SCP 049 was one of
the most traumatic experiences of his
life one that would stay with him
forever and be the reason he would
always be afraid of SCP
682 the SCP Foundation specializes in
tracking down and containing anomalies
that are difficult to find and that
often will do anything they can to avoid
being found one anomaly in particular
hates being seen more than anything and
will punish anyone who looks at its face
with a horrific fate scp096 is a
mysterious creature not only because it
destroys anyone who sees what it truly
looks like no one is entirely certain
where it came from what exactly it is or
why it reacts so violently to being
perceived there are however several
theories as to the Shy Guy's origin and
none of them are particularly cheerful
some suggest an experiment gone wrong
others believe it to be the last
remaining member of an unknown species
of mountain dwelling humanoids but one
theory about SCP 96's origin stands out
as particularly tragic in nature in this
story scp096 was not always a long limed
pale Beast cowering in the corner and
hiding its face from the world it was
once an ordinary man like anyone you
might pass on the street he was
someone's son someone's friend a person
with hopes dreams and passions a human
being who through anomalous
circumstances Beyond his control was
made into a monster many years ago there
was a mountaineer named Jack all his
adult life he had been obsessed with
reaching higher and higher Peaks
climbing Every Mountain he could in
order to test his limits Pit himself
against the power of nature and bask in
the sweet reward that was the view from
the top it began as a sport a way to
build up strength while taking in
incredible natural beauty but over time
as he conquered increasingly difficult
challenges it became an obsession like
every Obsession eventually does climbing
mountains began to take over his life
driving everything else away he
struggled to hold down a job his
marriage fell apart and his relationship
to his friends and family became
increasingly distant and strained still
he couldn't bring himself to care much
he spent his alone time in the
wilderness or every so often embarking
on trips with other Mountaineers whether
he was going at it Solo or working with
others he was living for the climb over
the years he took on serot to in
Argentina theer in Switzerland and
Denali in Alaska he especially enjoyed
climbing in extreme cold raving the ice
and snow know as he embarked on his
climbs the few fellow Mountaineers he
kept up with gave him the nickname Jack
Frost after years of refining his craft
building his strength he set his sights
on the highest mountain in the world his
personal white whale Mount Everest
itself it was one of the deadliest
climbs in the world with its staggering
height storms and Frozen graveyard of
Fallen climbers dotting the snowy
surface but he was determined he would
not join the ranks of the Fallen but
instead be one of the Victorious that
reached the top of Everest and came back
down in one piece he could feel it in
his bones Jack arrived in Nepal with a
pack full of climbing equipment the best
boots money could buy and layers upon
layers of clothing to keep himself warm
on the journey to the summit he lowered
his goggles over his eyes summoned his
courage and prepared for the incredibly
difficult climb the cold seeped into his
core the winds nipped at his face numn
numbing his nose and leeching through
his gloves and boots as he went but Jack
pressed on he welcomed the sensation the
bite of it it was a reminder that he was
still here that he was still alive as
long as he could feel the pain he knew
he was all right he knew that it was
when the cold faded away turned to
paradoxical feelings of warmth and
sleepiness that a mountaineer was truly
in trouble as he navigated the harsh
mountain landscape Jack occasionally let
his eyes drift off course taking in the
sights around him he could see shocks of
blue green and red the distant bright
colors of boots jackets and hats
belonging to the Fallen climbers that
came before him those who collaps from
exhaustion who gave in to altitude
sickness or succumbed to the cold
momento Mory he said softly to himself
these frozen bodies represented that
everpresent reminder of mortality of
death lurking just out of sight he would
not come for him though not today not on
this journey he wouldn't let it the
hours blurred together within the crunch
of the ice beneath his boots the Dig of
climbing hooks into the Earth the tug of
his trusty ropes as he ascended ever
higher Jack came to a stop there was no
next step to take nowhere higher that he
could go he had reached the summit the
white whale was captured and Everest was
his for the very first time he was truly
on top of the world now that he had made
it to the highest point there was the
all-important task of climbing back down
at this altitude he was still in the
death zone the place where human
acclimatization was impossible this was
the tricky part the point at which even
the most experienced of climbers might
get lost in the Euphoria of the
achievement and might let their
attention slip any mistake during his
descent and EM Miss step could be the
thing that cost him his life there was
no room for error and no time to waste
just as Jack prepared to make his
descent he saw a figure pulling itself
over the ridge from a distance it looked
like a fellow climber he noticed the
Curious lack of equipment and the way
the person seemed to be making their way
up the mountain with nothing but their
hands but perhaps they lost their pack
or left it behind for some reason the
figure was dressed in all white from
their Hood to their boots with a large
pair of Black Mountain goggles covering
what little of their face was wasn't
concealed by the hood uncertain if the
figure was in need of assistance and
surprised to see another Soul on the
mountain with him jack waved at the
figure everything okay he called there
was no response but the figure turned to
look at him at least he thought it was
looking at him he couldn't see its eyes
through the goggles but he felt the
distinct sensation of it locking its
gaze with his just the same as soon as
the figure turned to look at him jack
began to feel strange the pain the sharp
sensation of the cold that he relied on
to ground himself and remember he was
really here began to blur around the
edges the feeling softened melting away
along with the ache in his muscles the
blurriness in his eyes the dry mouth
that had nagged at him for hours he felt
unbalanced unmowed a ship with no anchor
he couldn't explain why but the sudden
relief from the cold made his chest
tighten with Primal Terror he did not
feel feel like one man encountering
another on the mountain he felt the way
he had years ago when he came face to
face with a mountain lion staring down a
predator and remembering all of a sudden
that humans do not naturally sit at the
top of the food chain this figure this
thing it was no man it was no person
Jack prepared to continue his desent to
get away from the strange Intruder as
quickly as possible but his feet would
not obey him his eyes could not break
contact with the figure in white that
was slowly beginning to advance toward
him one slow step at a time it was in no
hurry it knew he was not going anywhere
anytime soon he trembled as the figure
Drew closer its inscrutable face hidden
beneath its hood and behind its goggles
he wished he could just see its face but
dreaded learning What secrets it was
hiding if only he could just unstick his
feet from the earth Break Free of this
spell that had fallen over over him he
could Escape but no matter how much his
muscles strained how he gritted his
teeth with effort he couldn't get away
as the entity came closer the cold
snapped back into his body but something
was different it was heightened like
every icy Breeze and freezing wind
layered on top of itself hardening his
muscles to rock crystallizing the very
blood in his veins he felt as if his
fingers if he tried to wriggle them
would snap off and fall to the ground
his eyes thrummed in their sockets his
lungs stretched to hold on to each
breath as the cold constricted its fist
around his chest he opened his mouth to
speak but his voice died in his throat
coming out in a weak Whisper of air now
the thing was close enough to touch him
and whatever Force had been holding him
still and upright released him it was as
if he were a marionette suspended in the
air and the Puppeteer released his
strings at once he crumpled led to the
snow covered ground in a heap his cheek
pressed into the Earth his eyes trained
helplessly on the still advancing figure
his lip formed the word please though he
could not tell exactly what he was
begging for his life his freedom a
painless death perhaps he struggled to
push himself to his feet but all the
strength had gone out of his limbs he
could barely lift his arm let alone
handle the weight of his whole body the
thing shaped like a man was right above
him glowering down through those opaque
goggles he still could not see its eyes
but somehow he could feel the way it was
looking at him hatred was radiating off
of it disdain and pure unadulterated
malice then it tilted its head to the
side thoughtfully and Jack's mind was
overwhelmed with images he felt the
Phantom sensation of sunlight on his
skin and springy green grass beneath his
bare feet he could see clear as day in
his Mind's Eye a forest in the middle of
summer Dew drops sparkling on the Petals
of wild flowers blowing in a gentle
sweet Breeze then he felt sand between
his toes smelled the seab breeze felt
the comfort and contentment of a nap on
the beach it was not offering these
things to him but something like them
something like peace it was offering him
a gift but he didn't want it he couldn't
take it he was Jack Frost damn it he
thrived in the cold the hardship he
didn't want some warm sleepy Fade Out of
existence if he went out it would be on
his terms doing the thing he had
dedicated his life to if he were going
to lose his life he wouldn't roll over
and just give it up it would need to be
Pride from his Frozen hands with every
last bit of strength he twisted his head
away from the entity's Gaze covering his
face with his hands it grabbed at him
shaking his shoulders trying to force
force him to uncover his face and meet
its gaze once more but he didn't budge
he wouldn't he couldn't then he felt the
energy shift as it realized he had
refused the gift that he would not
welcome the paradoxical feelings of heat
and security and slip away as it was
asking him to but it was not a victory
he swore he could hear a voice in his
mind
say very well you wish to be part of the
mountain I will make
so the world went white as Jack's eyes
rolled back in his head his spine
curving back until it snapped his jaw
cracked and distended his arms and legs
stretched out long and twisted his body
contorted at unnatural angles as the
entity began to rearrange his very being
as the agony ripped through him snapping
his bones and tearing his muscles Jack
kept his face cradled in his hands he
remained in that position even as he
cried his voice horse as the pure fear
and pain overwhelmed his senses until he
forgot his own name forgot he was ever a
man at all when Jack was no more when
something else sat there in his place
pale and shivering body racked with sobs
the king of the mountain turned and left
him there alone with his misery still he
would not uncover his face he would not
let himself be vulnerable and would not
look up days later a group of
Mountaineers reached the summit of
Everest and spotted a hairless figure
crouched in the snow weeping softly are
you all right one of them asked the
figure lifted its head slowly and locked
eyes with the strangers its eyes widened
in horror its mouth stretched impossibly
wide in a wordless scream of rage and
hurt and with nothing human left in its
mind or heart scp096 took its very first
victim doors burst open allowing the
gurnie to come speeding through followed
by a gaggle of concerned Foundation
scientists and medical personnel
everyone was a buzz anxious at the
troubling development and fearful over
the fate of the patient lying on the
examination bed it wasn't exactly a rare
occurrence for someone working at an SCP
Foundation facility to need serious
medical treatment more often because of
a grievous injury or psychological
episode incurred whenever a dangerous
anomaly breached containment after all
working for the foundation was nothing
if not hazardous to your health but
Personnel being injured that was so
commonplace at the foundation that it
was practically mundane just another
ordinary part of the job it certainly
never garnered this much attention with
every researcher and medic on site all
clamoring to try and assist or even just
get a look at who was on the gurnie it
wasn't a member of personnel it was an
anomaly SCP 049 was sick nothing about
the plague doctor's Behavior had seemed
out of the ordinary he was normal at
least as much as a beak masked robe
creature could be until that is one
morning SCP 049 had just collapsed in
his holding cell the security camera
watching him had recorded the entire or
deal with guards alerting the research
teams and eventually calling paramedics
to come and escort the plague doctor to
the on-site infirmary SCP 049 was
noticeably weaker confused even afraid
some onlookers seemed to think H there's
no sign of physical injury Dr Cooper
noted aloud trying his best to examine
SCP 049 while the gurnie was racing down
the hallways all without touching the
plague doctor's skin directly one touch
and he would die in an instant all signs
seemed to point to something internal
nobody had entered SCP 049 cell in the
previous 24 hours the security footage
proved that the only people who had even
come close to the plague doctor were
authorized Foundation staff Dr Cooper
was right there was no indication that
SCP 049 had suffered any external damage
if he'd been attacked it would have been
caught by the security footage it had to
be some kind of illness the plague
doctor was slipping in and out of
Consciousness he could move and groan
slightly but only had a few fleeting
periods of Lucidity but if he was Ill
what with what was the cause any
symptoms if there had been any leading
up to his collapse must have been so
subtle that they had gone completely
undetected by everyone that had recently
encountered SCP 049 and was there a risk
of cross-contamination was everyone
rushing alongside or following the
speeding gine now infected also as they
reached the infirmary Foundation Medics
were already waiting having prepped the
area for SCP 049 arrival wearing gloves
over their hands to avoid lethal direct
skin contact the medical staff hoisted
SC SCP 049 onto a bed just as Dr oml
arrived pushing his way through the
crowd of other researchers and doctors
who had piled into the Sick Bay all
right the show's over back up and give
him some room to breathe oml had shouted
before turning to get a closer look at
SCP 049 we've had a similar situation to
this before if it goes the same way then
there's nothing to worry about at that
moment SCP 049 briefly became Lucid once
more 049 it's Dr om can you hear me yes
yes I can the plague doctor replied
weakly please help me doctor well I I'll
do my bestl said trying to keep the beak
surgeon spirits up it's a real good
thing I was here that time you laid an
egg at least we know what to expect this
time right I am not not laying another
egg SCP 049 rasped through his beak his
pain obvious in his tone what that what
the heck's going on it happened he
answered pestilence it is the p Ence
before losing Consciousness again the
entire infirmary went deathly silent the
pestilence the vaguely defined disease
that SCP 049 spent his life seeking out
and trying to cure now it had infected
him and could potentially claim his life
unless the foundation could help him
there was one big problem nobody had any
idea exactly what the pestilence really
was except for SCP 049 the next few
hours were a Non-Stop circus an
emergency quarantine order was issued as
everyone that had accompanied the gurnie
had to be screened and tested for any
possible signs of contagion if the
pestilence had actually managed to
infect SCP 049 there was a high chance
it could spread especially with so many
research staff and Medics present the
infirmary was sealed off any of the
Medics who were cleared were issued a
hazmat suit so they could continue to
Aid the sick plague doctor although
confirming that staff were 100% clear of
the pestilence wasn't exactly
straightforward nobody knew what signs
or symptoms to even look for normally it
was only SCP 049 and him alone that
could sense the presence of the
pestilence in a human being and is only
cure was turning them into a zombified
instance of SCP
049-2 a momentary Panic started to
spread amongst the foundation Personnel
who had been near SCP 049 stemming from
one idea of about what the pestilence
really was the Bubonic plague it didn't
seem too far of a stretch given SCP 049
appearance resembling the clothing worn
by medieval plague doctors when the
Black Death ravaged most of Europe
during the
1300s given that the Bubonic plague was
fatal once this paranoid rumor set in
amongst the foundation's staff some
began to break down believing they had
contracted the deadly medieval infection
however after several hours of
additional screening and Tes
nobody on site showed even a hint of
Bubonic plague in their systems but all
the while SCP 049 wasn't getting any
better we're still in the dark here Dr
oml said his frustration fogging up the
visor of his hazmat suit if the
pestilence isn't bubanic plague then
what the hell is it and how do we cure
it I've been going through the archives
every interaction that SCP 049 has ever
had that we've got recorded and so far
there's nothing conclusive Dr Cooper
replied swiping through various incident
reports on a tablet all the foundation
had ever truly known of the pestilence
was based on SCP 049 own testimony they
were aware it was an Insidious infection
capable of ultimately causing death in a
subject that had contracted it but
anyone that SCP 049 had ever operated on
and turned into an SCP 049-2 zombie
hadn't previously exhibited any
anomalous or even just unusual symptoms
the plague doctor had only ever
described the disease in vague terms and
he alone had been able to sense it I
went back over Dr Ham's notes after his
interview with SCP 049 Cooper continued
based on these it looks like there are a
few working theories about what the
pestilence really is but but whatl
replied come on out with it well they're
pretty abstract to say the least the
fellow Foundation researcher admitted
The Entity is at the top of his list
you're kidding Dr oml sighed The Entity
was something that the foundation had
long been aware of but had no way of
confirming if it even existed it had
been learned about from SCP 5000 a
heavily damaged absolute exclusion
harness the suit's data logs told of an
alternate timeline where in the SCP
Foundation turned on humanity and began
using various anomalies to commit a
worldwide apocalypse this had been done
according to the information recovered
from the harness in order to combat a
being known only as the entity or it
apparently this being had managed to
latch on to the human Race's collective
subconscious and had been manipulating
the entire planet for some nefarious
reason the entity was what caused humans
to feel pain and subsequently fed on
that pain although nobody was aware of
its intentions the foundation of this
SCP 5000 timeline had deemed it to be so
diabolical that they had resorted to
wiping out Humanity at all costs to
prevent The Entity from ever succeeding
I think it's the theory with legs one of
the Medics chimed in it can't be it's so
dumb Dr omel replied dismissively
scratching his head exactly it's so dumb
but so brilliant the medic replied no
it's just dumbel shouted Dr 's right
according to the logs from SCP 5000 The
Entity affects everyone Dr Cooper
pointed out but SCP 049 doesn't attempt
to operate on everyone it meets if it
was trying to combat The Entity it would
have to cure every human being alive
where are we at with treating SCP 049 Dr
oml asked the longer we spend yakking
and doing nothing he could be getting
even closer to death uh we're seeing no
chance the medic answered solemnly the
foundation's immediate course of action
was to administer SCP 049 with a single
dose of SCP 500 also known as the
Panacea coming in the form of a red pill
SCP 500 was known to cure a person of
all diseases but as we know Panacea
doesn't have one consistent rate of
Effectiveness the medic explained it can
take longer to heal a subject depending
on the disease they've been infected
with so SCP 500 could be working Dr RL
asked like I've said we've not detected
any change in SCP 049 condition the
medic replied it could be that the
treatment isn't working at all because
it can't isolate the pestilence on the
plague doctor's system as far as SCP 500
might know there's nothing for it to
actually heal great really that's just
wonderful we have a miracle kill that
works on any illness and it's just not
doing what it's meant to oml side what
about next of kin any luck there he's
notoriously good at evading capture
believe me I know but if we tell him
what's going on not my department the
medic Shrugged I'd say the fact nobody's
brought him in yet means that our field
agents still haven't found him but your
guess is as good as mine oh very
insightful Dr oml said his frustration
coming out as sarcasm just get the hell
out of here and see what you can do for
SCP 049 and send someone else to give us
updates next time hold onl Dr Cooper
interjected take a look at Dr Ham's
notes and I've come up with another
theory about the pestilence here well
what is it's death the room felt quiet
death as in the fundamental law of the
entire universe the entire state of not
being alive oml exploded with outraged
disbelief listen what if specifically
dying of natural causes could itself be
the pestilence ham was pretty old when
he first interviewed SCP 049 right and
they had a number of sessions together
until one day SCP 049 turns on him
senses the pestilence and gives Dr Ham
the whole treatment he zombified him I
know you don't need to be COI Cooper
right well during their very first
interview at site 19 049 said he could
sense a lot of death there but not all
had that many traces of the pestilence
the researcher explained so what if SCP
049 had started to realize the odd
little signs of Dr Ham aging graying
hair wrinkles The Usual Suspects and
instead of waiting for ham to die he
cured him immediately here in an
interview 049 said the following do you
wait to remove roding Timbers until the
hall collapses on top of you no you find
them and you pull them out and replace
them with those Untouched by rot and
most of all you do not simply mock the
structure because it now looks different
to you it is strong it is free of
disease but not everyone he's killed or
cured has been Ham's age there's no way
we would have spotted that pattern nol
reasoned and if he was trying to stop
people dying he wouldn't start out his
procedure with that lethal Touch of his
think about it though how does SCP 049
cure people you said it yourself he
zombifies them he reanimates them we're
all infected to him everyone dies after
all so he cures that with those horrific
resurrections and thus C's death a
flabbergasted Dr omel finished the
sentence so assuming you're right and
the pestilence really is just death
itself SCP is in the other room dying
from completely natural causes and that
might be the only thing even we can't
fix Dr Cooper nodded solemnly tell that
to the 05 Council oml muttered suddenly
one of the Medics a different one as
requested came bursting into the room
sir the the next of kin one of the field
agents has recovered SC SCP 049-j the
plague doctor was quickly rushed into an
operating theater while doctors omel and
Cooper watched from Beyond a glass
screen a shorter version of SCP 049 his
son SCP 049-j was guided into the room
the little plague doctor timidly
approached its father are you sure this
will work Dr Cooper asked I read the
file on SCP 049-j apparently despite all
its claims of being a magical wizard
doctor he's never actually healed
anything made a few conditions even
worse in fact I was around when Junior
over there was born Dr oml said you know
what SCP 049 said to me when his egg
hatched what he is the cure that's how I
know this is going to work the cultist
screamed the long and spindly but
unimaginably powerful arm of the shy guy
had him by the leg dragging him
backwards his fingernails carving deep
ruts into the floor his friend was
already already on the run but his death
warrant had been sealed by a glance in
the history of evil plans rarely has an
evil plan backfired so spectacularly as
the shy guy bellowed destroying its
latest prey and Galloping after the
second which would soon become the third
and the fourth and the fifth and so much
more as the Personnel of the SCP
Foundation caught unplanned glimpses of
his terrible face it would take a God to
to undo the chaos that was unfolding the
exact same God that these two idiot
cultists were here to destroy the plan
had seemed so simple so perfectly
straightforward on paper sneak into the
SCP Foundation and assassinate SC SCP
343 that being said even diluted
cultists of the Scarlet King knew that
killing the anomaly believed to be God
himself was going to be far easier in
theory than in practice and yet neither
one of this Intrepid pair of foundation
impersonators could ever have predicted
things would go this bad several years
earlier Zachary and cash were nothing
more than a pair of social shuttin
trolling Forums on the internet from the
secluded sanctuary of their basements in
fact it was on a particular one of these
forums that would lead to the pair
eventually meeting in person parat a
deep web online space for discussions of
the Supernatural Well there was nothing
inherently Insidious about parwat itself
it did draw in those who were interested
in the Paranormal and even the anomalous
like Zack and cash and that made the
Forum the perfect recruitment tool for
those whose intentions were far more
nefarious both men were individually
approached by another user who was only
known by a screen name
CSK over some lengthy conversations with
with this mysterious third party both
Zach and cash found themselves being
convinced into believing the court
tenants of a murderous cult that revered
a conceptual deity the children of the
Scarlet King and it was during a secret
Gathering of their fellow members that
cash and Zach would not only meet but
find themselves specifically tasked with
a mission that was meant to clear the
way for the Scarlet King to enter our
reality simply put the two of them were
tasked with killing God the plan was
devised by one of the longer standing
Children of the Scarlet King who
divulged their Cults knowledge of the
SCP Foundation specifically an entity
known as SCP 343 a powerful reality
warper who had claimed to be the
architect of the very universe itself in
the eyes of the Scarlet King's followers
this meant that as SCP 343 could pose a
direct threat to the Ascension of their
destructive deity if the Scarlet King
was ever to gain access to this universe
there was a high chance SCP 343 could
oppose him so with stolen credentials
and Foundation Personnel Garb Zach and
cash were sent into remove SCP 343 from
the equation it goes without saying that
killing a being believed to be God
himself was hardly an easy goal to
achieve nobody could just poison SCP 343
or take him out using Conventional
Weapons or even use any other typical
methods of assassination that would work
on a human target instead Zach and cash
needed to get creative luckily there was
another anomaly kept contained by the
SCP Foundation that the children of the
Scarlet King had thought would be
perfect for the job it was a miniature
Event Horizon a black sphere that could
pull any nearby matter into itself
anything brought within the vicinity of
this anomalous Wormhole would quickly be
sucked in and ultimately lost forever
with no chance of retrieval sure it
might not kill SCP 343 strictly speaking
but it could certainly remove him from
play leaving the universe unprotected
against the rise of the Scarlet King
however there was one tiny problem one
otherwise minute detail that because it
went uncorrected jeopardized the whole
plan it could have been down to
inaccurate information that the children
of the Scarlet King had on the SCP
Foundation after all the organization
was known for keeping its operations and
even its very existence a closely
guarded secret or perhaps Sheely due to
human error the wrong number was said by
the wrong cultist at the wrong moment
misheard or misread leading to a four
being replaced with a six you see the
miniature Event Horizon was designated
as SCP
094 but by mistake Z back in cash had
slipped undetected into the foundation
in search of scp096
unaware that anomaly was far from what
they were expecting the look of Terror
on Zach's face appeared instantly as the
pair of scarlet King Fanatics open the
door to the containment cell that same
horrified look had vanished just as
quickly the second that scp096 took
notice of the two new visitors in the
blink of an eye the abnormally
proportioned humanoid anomaly had gone
from being hunched over in a corner
gently rocking itself to standing
directly in front of Zach and cash
towering over them both and screeching
incoherently cash turned and ran
abandoning his cultist compatriot as
Zach screamed in fear the shy guy had
grabbed him a moment later his screams
had been silenced thanks to scp096
cash had no idea what the creature was
all he knew was it certainly wasn't the
miniaturized black hole goal he and Zach
had been sent to find but he tried to
keep the original goal in mind even in a
moment of Crisis take out SCP 343 so
that the Scarlet King could rise maybe
this other anomaly whatever it was could
stand a chance against the reality
warper cash would never get to find out
however as he was tackled To The Ground
by a foundation security team as he
turned the corner but scp096 had been
hot on the cultists heels and had
appeared behind him just as he was being
restrained by security officers and the
whole unit could see the shy guy now
which meant not one of them stood a
chance meanwhile elsewhere in the
facility oblivious to the Carnage of the
unfolding Containment Breach SCP 343 was
enjoying a stroll around the foundation
site with a hamburger in one hand and a
milkshake in the other he had spent most
of the afternoon the way he usually did
phasing out of reality to an
extra-dimensional astral plane outside
of our known universe where he could
privately enjoy a game of Solitaire
using a deck of cards conjured out of
nothingness Upon returning polishing off
the drags of his lunch which he also
willed into existence from nowhere SCP
343 barely noticed that the entire
Foundation seemed to be on Red Alert or
more accurately he did notice he just
didn't do much to help you see one of
the more notable things about SCP 343
aside from the fact that he can use his
anomalous abilities to do literally
anything imaginable is that he very much
enjoys taking a back seat he claims that
after creating the universe he got tired
of having to be in control of everything
everywhere all at once good movie by the
way and so while SCP 343 could write
every wrong and solve every problem in
the entire universe he chooses not to
all to pursue the illusion of giving up
control and leaving the universe to its
own devices that is unless something
tries to to harm him directly and
something was very much about to while
the pair of scarlet King cultists who
had accidentally set SC scp096 free were
already dead they' unknowingly started a
chain reaction the foundation
desperately dispatched more of its
Personnel to try and recontain the shy
guy but the more they sent the more of
them observed the creature this gave
scp096 even more targets extending its
rage State as it zipped through the
foundation killing everyone that had
clasped eyes on it until that rage field
Rampage led to coincidentally cross
paths with SCP 343 would just walk
through a wall on his way back to his
cell right into the path of scp096
oh dear dear me SCP 343 sighed finishing
the remainder of his milkshake before
making the empty cup and straw disappear
it's been some time hasn't it Ian my boy
look at what what's become of you for a
moment scp096 seemed to pause its pale
skin flecked with droplets of blood
thanks to the sheer number of guards and
researchers it had torn through for
daring to look at it I see you're still
having the same old troubles the reality
warper continued reacting eerily calmly
and casually towards the Towering
monster you know you really ought to
work on your confidence that did it the
sentence touched a nerve within the shy
guy giv giving it a Pang of sadness that
erupted quickly into an unbridled rage
it did not matter that SCP 343 was a
powerful anomaly with the ability to do
almost anything he had still looked at
scp096 in fact he was looking directly
at it and that meant he had to go his
fate was sealed as the creature began
wailing and charging straight for SCP
343 with a casual wave of his hand God
swiped the creature aside sending us
cp09 six flying thrown telekinetically
much to its surprise the creature found
itself phasing through walls as it
sailed between corridors and other
containment Chambers in and out in and
out until it sailed through the solid
steel walls of its own cell Landing
right back in the corner that it had
started in but rather than returned to
crying in a fetal position as it
normally did scp096 got right back up
and raced back through the halls of the
facility homing in on CP 343 being sent
back to its room was enough to keep the
shy guys's rage State active and it
hadn't changed the fact that God had
still looked at it so he had to kill him
traveling at anomalous speeds scp096
blinked into existence right behind SCP
343 as he sat down and relaxed in his
favorite chair the horrific humanoid
shrieked loudly although SCP 343 didn't
turn around to look at it he already
knew it was there he had sens it even
before it left its cell with yet another
lazy swish of his hand as CP 343 sent
the shy guy away this time scp096
realized its long legs seemed to be
moving independently walking backwards
along the exact same steps it had taken
to get into SCP 343's Containment
chamber it continued going backwards and
despite its frustrated attempts to rush
back towards the reality warping old man
it couldn't little did the shy guy
realize it wasn't the only one SCP 343's
command over the fundamental laws of the
universe was so great that he had
altered time itself everything was now
running in Reverse albeit for a few
short moments birds in the sky were
flying backwards waterfalls were flowing
upwards the Earth was spinning in the
opposite direction on its axis
everything in existence was like an old
VCR tape being rewound until scp096
found itself once once again back in its
cell now the shy guy was mad really
really mad the M SCP 343 allowed time to
return to its normal forward
chronological flow scp096 once again
raced out of its containment chamber
hunting down the latest person to have
seen its wide jawed face usually nothing
could stop scp096 from catching up to
its Target often killing them without
fail but the fact that SCP 343 could so
easily re work the rules of the universe
to send it back to its room made the
self-conscious creature all the more
agitated and it was only going to get
worse and worse scp096 kept trying
infamously Relentless but every time SCP
343 presented some new unpredictable way
of stopping the shy guy from getting to
him on one attempt he caused the
creatures atams to rearrange themselves
into long strands the closer it got
effectively turning into shyy spaghetti
during another SCP 343 actually reworked
the way that site Works across the
entire universe making it so that on a
conceptual level he technically never
looked at scp096 according to this newly
redefined way of seeing things every
time SC SCP 343 set the shy guy back but
never deterred him he kept coming back
that is until bored by the constant back
and forth between them SCP 343 waited
for scp096
to arrive next to him once again at that
moment he snapped his fingers and the
creature stopped in its tracks a story
filled its mind the story of a once
normal kid this young child had been
bullied and ostracized by other children
made fun of for his appearance they
became depressed self-loathing keeping
away from everyone out of fear that
they'd be taunted the child started to
hide their face desperate that nobody
look at them and laugh listen SCP 343
told scp096 there was nothing around
them the universe had seemingly faded
away as the pair stood in a pocket of
space outside of reality just listen
closely silence not a whisper not even
the creature's own breathing could be
heard no one is laughing at you anymore
my son SCP 343 whispered it is okay you
can stop now there is nobody left who
can hurt you with that SCP 0 96's very
reason for being had ceased the shy guy
didn't exist anymore it didn't need to
restoring the universe to its previous
state with another click of his fingers
SCP 343 was free to sit back in his
chair and relax there he could continue
pretending he wasn't in control the SCP
foundation's existence might be a
frightening thing to some but if you ask
us it's comforting of course the
existence of the foundation implies the
existence of all the Mind meltingly
terrifying entities they Combat on a
daily basis but doesn't it put your mind
at least a little at ease to know
somebody out there knows what's going on
after all sometimes knowledge is the
only light we have in the darkness it is
Humanity's greatest strength to know
things and to act accordingly from
knowledge we can understand our enemies
and the threats they pose against us
from knowledge we can build sturdier
defense
from knowledge we can develop the means
to finally effectively strike back and
nobody among the ranks of humanity has
more knowledge than the SCP Foundation
so what happens when the knowledge of
the SCP Foundation fails us what happens
when a concept eludes even them a
concept like say SC SCP
2317 an old wooden door that hides
within a truly terrible secret a secret
known by many as the devour of Worlds a
beast every bit as powerful and
unpleasant as that name suggests the SCP
Foundation performs a complex set of
rituals every single day to keep him
contained and if the top Rass of the
foundation is to be believed then these
rituals are effective but I think we all
know better than to believe everything
we're told around here don't we the
truth is beyond the wooden door known as
SCP
2317 there is a hellish desert World
underneath which the Devourer of Worlds
awaits he is kept in place Bound by
ancient chains created by a race that
has long since been lost to the history
books and while the foundation tells its
underlings that the rituals d-class
Personnel perform here every day helps
to keep these chains in place this is
little more than a placebo the rituals
only exist to make the foundation feel
like they're doing something to buy time
while they figure out an actual lasting
solution in reality based on the
foundation's current knowledge These
Chains could break any day now and sadly
there's nothing they can do about it
this may seem like the worst possible
truth to learn but we can think of one
even worse truth that any day now is
today when the chain breaks the ground
begins to rumble worldwide Like An
Earthquake so great it might even split
the planet in two no conventional
scientist anywhere in the world has any
idea what's happening but the SCP
Foundation does for the first time in
recorded history the entire 05 Council
are quaking it's Judgment Day and there
every sin is on an Express trip back to
get them they put out a call to dispatch
every single mobile task force worldwide
to come to site 19 and combat this new
threat but deep down the council members
silently worried that this would be
about as effective as the Sham rituals
they claimed every day would protect
protect them meanwhile site 19 exploded
most of the foundation personnel and
anomalies stationed there perished in an
instant as a giant clawed hand rose out
of the ground grasping at the sunlight
for the first time in millions of years
since imprisonment its sheer size
hundreds of kilometers in height
displaces and destroys the land around
it as it climbs free from the earth the
devour of Worlds is a monster of such
magnitude that it dwarfs even the
foundation's mightiest weapons but their
mobile task Forces fight valiantly or
perhaps foolishly nonetheless the
foundation went in with its finest
resources and weaponry from Advanced
cruise missiles to classified laser
projectile weapons that conventional
militaries wouldn't be finding for
another century and all of it amounted
to be the strength of getting a mid-rate
birthday Clown's cheap cream pie to the
face the thick scaly hide of the Beast
somehow rejected everything they threw
at it Jets were scrambled flying around
the devour gargantuan head and
preppering its great eye with bullets
followed by heat guided Rockets nothing
the monster simply swatted them out of
the air with its claws down below ground
forces mobilized on Mass from tanks to
turrets unleashing all kinds of Hell
onto the devour of Worlds from below and
still what good did it do the monster
simply kept walking killing thousands
with every footfall its magnitude was
simply a unfathomable Scranton reality
anchors were placed at its feet in hopes
of creating some kind of trap but its
ancient feet defied their Force every
mobile task force from hammer down to
samsara did what they could and what
they could do ultimately amounted to a
fat lot of nothing the Rampage of the
Devourer was undeterred within an hour
he would reach a population Center and
then true hell would be Unleashed upon
the human race but sometimes the only
thing that could destroy something
inhuman was something so much more than
human over in the low-risk humanoid
containment center of Psych 17 SCP 343
perhaps better known as God was watching
all the horror unfold in his Mind's Eye
so the Devourer was finally free and
Wrecking havoc on the world that he put
so much effort into creating no no that
simply would not do how could he let
such a vulgar creature taking billions
of years of beauty love of kindness
happiness and natural majesty and turn
it all into Ash and dust he would not
stand for it but God while unimaginably
powerful is a philosopher not a warrior
who would be not only beneath his
Celestial position but dangerous for all
life on Earth if he were to Unleash the
Power required to destroy the Devourer
himself the armies of God are the
greatest in heaven or Earth but he would
need a champion to lead them and while
the operatives of the SCP Foundation
fought and died bravely for the human
race SCP 343 blipped out of sight 17 and
reappeared in the Middle East where his
Champion would be waiting guarding the
gate to Paradise SCP 001 in this case
known as the gate Guardian a huge
glowing humanoid with wings made of fire
and a sword hotter than the sun capable
of cleaving its enemies apart on the
atomic level typically any being who
traveled within a kilom of the gate
Guardian would receive this treatment a
strike so powerful that in the aftermath
not even dust would remain but when SC
SCP 343 appeared mere feet away from the
mighty gate Guardian the guardian fell
to one knee and bowed its glowing head
in holy reverence Master the guardian
said you have returned to me at long
last I will do thy bidding what must be
done youel God said Gravely an enemy is
at the gates one more powerful than this
world has ever known battle him while I
gather the armies do whatever it takes
he must be stopped the gate Guardian
Uriel Rose to his feet spreading his
great Wings of Fire it shall be done my
Lord Uriel boomed and faster than any
human being could possibly perceive it
he had taken off into the sky leaving
the gate behind him unguarded for the
first time in the memory of the human
race God's side it was time to finally
open it back with the devour and the
mobile Task Force Army trying in vain to
slow his advance for the most part the
creature's hide was so thick it was hard
to even know if he noticed most of the
puny humans firing on it some of the
ones down below driven half mad with
fear rage and the crushing weight of
futility pulled out knives swords and
bayonets and ran at the creatur's feet
stabbing away even as their blades were
blunted and destroyed of course of
course the devour of Worlds paid no mind
to them it had something else in its
sights a human City a mere handful of
steps away yes yes so teeming with life
such delicious morsels the Devourer
would live up to his terrifying namesake
and feast on them all yes yes it would
be delicious as he crushed further
thousands of mobile task force soldiers
below him just by walking he could
hardly wait down below things had never
seemed so hopeless was this how it ended
one impotent Last Stand as a hungry
monster of inconceivable size bulldozed
through life and civilization and left
nothing nobody in its wake was this how
the complicated but proud story of the
human race would come to an end down
here in the worthless blood soaked mud
that's when something changed the sky
once blotted out with the devour shadow
was lit up by a brilliant white light a
light so dazzling so holy and pure that
it gave even the Devourer pause the
human beings down below wept with joy
and numinous awe it was him it was SCP
001 the gate Guardian spreading his
fiery wings and drawing his solar sword
my master ordered me to destroy you his
deafening psychic voice boomed and thus
you shall be destroyed prepare to meet
your
maker the devour immediately let out a
world shaking Roar so powerful that many
of the humans down below felt their
brains rattling and their ears literally
beginning to bleed the Beast reached for
urio with its huge clawed hand moving at
impossible speeds for a creature at size
onlookers gasped in shock luckily for as
surprisingly fast as the devour of
Worlds was Uriel was faster like a flash
of an exploding light bulb the guardian
darted Ed out of the devour palm and
cleaved a glowing gash into the
monster's wrist with his solar sword the
creature growled taken off guard it was
the first time in millions of years
since it was attacked and bound by those
impossible Celestial armies that it had
felt pain what was this mysterious
Warrior of fire all the devour knew was
that if it wanted to turn the planet
Earth into an all can eat buffet it
would need to do away with this glowing
nuisance first die
the psychic voice of the gate Guardian
commanded as it flew in for another
strike this time cleaving into the
beast's torso and leaving a long glowing
scar but he didn't stop there the gate
Guardian had changed posture from a
defensive territorial stance to an
allout offensive war path as commanded
by his all powerful Master Uriel was not
arrogant he could see that the Beast he
was battling was undeniably formidable
but he had slain formidable enemies
before and and he would do so again now
taking advantage of the comparative
slowness and clunkiness of the Devourer
a natural side effect of its truly
immense size Uriel decided to stay
mobile flying around the Devourer like
an electron orbiting the nucleus of an
atom at any moment that he with his
Warrior's judgment detected an opening a
weakness he flew in and struck with
extreme Fury leaving another glowing
scar in the monster's thick scales that
fizzled with the impossible heat of his
sword each time the Beast gave a grunt
or a growl in confused pain as it
desperately flailed to try and grab the
holy Warrior meanwhile thep Foundation
had figured out what was happening and
was reorienting its focus while the gate
Guardian fought against and distracted
the devour of Worlds all surviving
Foundation Personnel under the
instruction of the 05 Council converged
on the nearest city to the Devourer they
would evacuate as many as they could
buying them more time to calculate some
kind of meaningful counter offensive to
to this XK Class end of the world
scenario if this really could be
Humanity's Last Stand they would go out
swinging and leave their opponent with a
black eye while the evacuation efforts
were underway yuriel continued his
Relentless assault against the Devourer
carving scar after scar into the
monster's body he could not tell if he
was leaving much lasting damage but at
the very least he was getting the
Abominations attention after striking
its body countless times though yua
finally felt bold enough to go against
the creature's obvious weak point its
huge staring cycloptic eye perhaps with
a decisive strike he could blind the
Beast faster than the speed of sound
yuriel orbited the beast's body and
reoriented himself in front of its eye
he could feel the nanocs passing as he
charged raising his sword now would be
the time to end this but wait what's
that why is the devours eyes suddenly
glowing red before even yuriel had time
to react a tremendous force of pure
energy blasted forth from the devour eye
bombarding the Angelic Soldier and
firing him straight into the ground
below he did not even know the monster
possessed such a power and now the force
of it was hammering him into the Earth
the blast kept going for a few more
seconds zapping uriel's strength and
introducing him to a long forgotten pain
when the beam was done firing Uriel felt
as though he could barely move he was a
Sitting Duck that's when the Devourer
began marching towards him every step
rattling the Earth even as the threat
loomed yuriel couldn't move was this the
end forgive me master Uriel said I have
failed you then Uriel noticed something
several projectiles firing towards the
devour head seemingly out of thin air a
volley of intercontinental ballistic
missiles each equipped with a nuclear
payload exploded against the creature's
head blasting it with a shock wave that
rattled the mighty creature on its feet
had human beings made such weapons if
they could still fight even after all
this Uriel thought then I must fight too
I must fight to my last breath as the
devour steadied itself recovering from
the nuclear bombardment to the Head
Uriel rose with a terrifying Warrior's
Roar feeling his holy power returned to
him his sword ignited and he charged
forward faster than ever before ready to
strike clear and true into the Devourer
wretched heart the before the Beast
could react Uriel shoved his sword into
the center of its chest causing veins of
agonizing flame to spread out over its
whole body at long last he had well and
truly harmed the unharmful that
knowledge Sanctified him even as the
devour of Worlds grabbed yuriel in his
fist and squeezed the life out of the
warrior for God for the last time good
the devour thought in its own way I can
finally carry on now you fought bravely
Uriel said a booming voice from above
the Beast your sacrifice will not be in
vain that much I promise you confused
the devour turned and looked Skyward
only to see a sight that struck pure and
undiluted awe into even him it was God
and his army SCP 343 floated in the sky
lightning emanating from his very being
around him glowing Angelic Warriors each
as large and as powerful as your and as
numerous as the stars in the sky above
God pointed at the Devourer now my
children he said take that thing apart
from me Agent Hogan hadn't seen what had
grabbed the commander the sounds of
blood curdling screams had made his eyes
instinctively snap shut Hogan kept both
eyes tightly closed nothing but Darkness
blotting out his vision even as the
desperate grally voiced yells of the
commander filled his ears then suddenly
there was a scream one that was abruptly
cut off with a heavy thud something
dropped to the ground close enough to
agent Hogan's feet that he could feel
the vibrations of it hitting the floor
through his boots it was the commander
completely still and Silent even though
he'd been trained to look danger in the
eye agent Hogan still didn't open his
eyes not even for a split second this
was the first time that anything like
this had ever happened and in the panic
and confusion his natural survival
instincts had overridden the SCP
foundation's various rules and protocols
in his head and right now something was
telling him not to look that something
was shifting and moving just beyond
agent Hogan's eyelids he could hear a
shuffling as something much taller than
an average human lumbered around it had
been wailing before shrieking in
uncontrollable and inconsolable despair
but now its cries had lowered to a soft
sobbing whimper when someone's eyes are
closed they aren't completely cut off
from the world around them just being
able to see doesn't entirely dull a
person's awareness most people have a
kind of sense a spatial alert that tells
them what's nearby even if they can't
see it and in this particular moment
agent Hogan was going haywire the thing
the thing Beyond his closed eyes was
moving towards him so close he could
feel its warm rancid breath on his skin
just knowing it was so close hearing it
breathe and sobb gently sensing its
standing so close to him it made the
agent's already pounding heart rate
start to climb he could feel beads of
sweat crawling down the side of his face
as the creature leaned in closer it
almost felt like it was trying to go him
into opening his eyes go on just take a
peek came a nagging gnawing voice at the
back of Hogan's mind he couldn't help it
it was a natural human response to be
curious but as intriguing of a sight as
it might have been the creature was far
more terrifying Hogan had no idea what
horror he'd be faced with if he even
opened his eyes for a second little did
he know forcing himself not to look
whether out of fear or pure survival
Instinct had saved the agent's life he
could sense the creature turn and start
to slink off getting further away again
as it lumbered around a corner on its
elongated legs still agent Hogan waited
a little longer before opening up his
eyes again just to be safe it had all
started around a month earlier when the
SCP Foundation had discovered a
potential anomaly was being housed by a
group known as the department of
abnormalities you see back then the SCP
Foundation wasn't quite the sprawling
ginormous anomaly containment
organization some might be familiar with
it was far from being in its infancy at
this point in time either but the
foundation was only just beginning to
expand its collection of dangerous and
unusual anomalies they had received word
of an anomaly that was being held in a
facility in stutgart Germany where
Department of abnormalities Personnel
had gone to Great Lengths to secure it
however despite all the measures they
put in place this creature was able to
escape and didn't leave a single
Survivor in its wake after Breaking Free
and so being unfamiliar with this kind
of situation the SCP Foundation had to
decide what the best course of action
would be the foundation dispatched a
retrieval team codenamed Zulu 9A to the
facility that the creature had broken
free from from the location in stutgart
Zulu 9A was able to track the anomaly's
movements to an undisclosed mountainous
region it was believed that this area
was either the creature's natural
habitat where it had initially been
captured or that the mountain at least
closely resembled the place that the
anomaly would recognize as home flying
aboard a chopper the Zulu 9A team
assumed they could simply approach the
creature and calmly coerce it long
enough for them to capture and escort it
back to base it turned out they were
very very wrong as their Chopper landed
nearby and the retrieval team closed in
on the creature the captain of zulu 9A
turned to talk to a foundation doctor
that had accompanied the unit that one
serendipitous action might have saved
his life because it meant he wasn't
looking at the
a sudden intense shriek rang out as the
creature started crying turning towards
the rest of the approached retrieval
unit in a panic they pulled their
triggers weapons erupting into a hail of
deafening gunfire but it had no effect
the creature dashed towards them
shrugging off every oncoming attack
completely unscathed but the Zulu 9A
team weren't so well defended by the
time the captain turned back around the
creature had already vanished seemingly
able to move much faster than first
anticipated maybe once they'd taken a
look at it the retrieval team thought
that the creature's long
disproportionate limbs would make its
movements clumsy and cumbersome not that
a single one of them was left standing
to verify that the captain was left
alone and stunned he hadn't seen what
had happened to his team only the
aftermath and it wasn't a pretty sight
before long backup arrived in the form
of zulu 9 B's team with the help of this
secondary unit the Captain was able to
eventually capture the creature and
remand it into SCP Foundation
containment how by placing a bag over
its head his theory was if it couldn't
see the retrieval team it couldn't
attack them and while this strategy
might have worked he was only half right
of course the SCP foundation's mandate
has always been to contain and study the
anomalies that it encounters and this
was all the more prevalent during these
earlier days of the organization so
naturally once the creature had
seemingly been captured and secured a
group of overzealous and eager
scientists were quick to step in so that
they could closely examine the anomaly
and for a time they were able to work
with little obstruction they could
determine the basic details about the
creatures physiology and have that
information logged in its very own file
on the SCP foundation's internal
database but one scientist made a very
fatal mistake during those early tests
and studies perhaps because the
foundation had already captured the
creature and secured it within the walls
of its own facility they believed it
posed no further threat to personel
anymore that it couldn't hurt to remove
the bag and take a closer look the very
instant the bag was removed chaos broke
loose it was as if someone had lit the
fuse of a firework only for it to
explode before they could rush to a safe
enough distance away not only were the
scientists studying the creature
horrified by the sight of its grotesque
wide jawed face but they were all
seconds away from meeting the same grim
and grizzly fate as the retrieval team
sent to capture it now they had seen its
face and the monster was loose within
the foundation at that particular point
in time the foundation's early mistakes
this kind of thing was unprecedented it
had never happened before not once and
nobody knew what to do most of the
anomalies they had encountered so far
were benign either harmless Oddities
passive and non-hostile creatures or
artifacts with a few strange or
unexplained properties but with no real
sentience to speak of but this was a
ferocious Abomination intent on causing
harm to the foundation's own staff so
someone needed to act and do so fast a
handful of armed Foundation agents
happened to be on site at the time
security officers hris Hogan and Stevens
as well as Sutton the surviving captain
from the Zulu 9A retrieval team the
second that the creature was seen and
began retaliating against those that had
seen its face deafening alarms began to
blare that was all the warning they
would get there were no special
containment procedures yet no protocol
or a standard procedure for something
like this the foundation didn't even
have a term for the situation that was
going on although after today they would
this was the SCP foundation's first ever
Containment Breach given that he'd been
involved in retrieving the creature that
was now on the loose Captain Sutton took
lead of the small group coordinating
them as their deao Commander don't worry
we just need to get another bag over its
head and get it back into containment he
instructed as calmly and confidently as
he could given the tense circumstances
this thing is highly aggressive but if
you stay out of sight it won't come
after you corners and stay frosty we'll
split into twos and fan out should have
more of a chance of catching him that
way little did Sutton realize his
misguided advice would cost him and
others their lives hendrickx and Steven
stumbled across the creature first
poking their heads around a corner they
spotted the tall Ry humanoid shape
passing along the corridor that ran
parallel to the one they stood in the
two agents saw the creature but as far
as they could tell it hadn't seen them
but that didn't matter just as they both
turned down the corner ready to Ambush
the anomaly The Towering spindly form of
the creature suddenly appeared behind
them screeching as it attacked hearing
the sound of the others falling prey to
the monster Captain Sutton and agent
Hogan rushed towards the source of their
fellow agents screams the DEA facto
commander of the group rushed a few
Paces ahead confident that he knew how
to get the upper hand against the
creature trailing behind him agent Hogan
had been swept up in the Panic of the
whole situation he had no idea what the
creature was only that half of the
retrieval team sent to capture it had
all died their weapons were useless
against it which made the gun Hogan
gripped and his trembling fingers feel
unre assuring ineffective Sutton turned
a corner down on the corridor ahead and
that had been when he locked eyes with
the creature seeing its face for the
first time he hadn't even caught a
proper glimpse of it when he' managed to
capture it in the mountains but now he
had seen it and it knew from around the
corner unable to see Sutton or the
monster agent Hogan let the Panic get
the better of him and closed his eyes an
action that had unknowingly saved his
life once the monster had passed him by
and agent Hogan had dared to open his
eyes again his mind started racing it
had seen him that much he was certain of
even with his eyes closed he had sensed
just how close to him the creature had
gotten to him it had to have seen him
and yet he was still alive Sutton had
said that it would attack anyone that it
saw unless Sutton had got it all wrong
the creature wasn't attacking anyone it
looked at it was going after anyone who
looked at it it was learning that key
difference that allowed agent Hogan to
gain the upper hand on the creature
however he quickly realized that the
number of people in the facility was
rapidly dwindling the longer the anomaly
was able to roam free the more
Foundation Personnel would see its face
and fall victim to its rage agent Hogan
realized what he would have to do send
out a message to the SCP Foundation hups
that this anomaly was only attacking
anyone who looked at it then he sealed
himself in the chamber where the
scientists had been examining the
creature they'd filmed the examination
all Hogan had to do was watch part of
the footage where the bag was removed
and look at the anomaly's face the
monster took care of the rest traveling
at impossible speeds scp096 appeared in
the room behind agent Hogan ever since
the SCP Foundation has poured
innumerable resources into ensuring they
have enough Personnel or specifically
trained to deal with containment
breaches some will even tell you that it
was this first incident that led to the
idea of mobile task Forces teams that
the foundation can deploy within moments
to respond to anomalies breaking out of
their containment of course who really
knows if that is true maybe half of it
actually happened and the rest was built
off rumors and hearsay if you sign up to
join one of the SCP foundation's mobile
task forces nowadays then perhaps your
commanding officer will tell you this
story during your basic training it
could be that they're trying to
intimidate you or just reemphasize how
important the role of the mtfs within
the foundation is one thing is for sure
though anyone assigned to guard as CP
96's chamber knows to close their eyes
in the event of another Containment
Breach it is certainly not unheard of
for a young girl to wake up in the
middle of the night looking for a glass
of water it is somewhat more exceptional
when this late night water Run results
in many many deaths unless of course
you're dealing with a very special young
girl SCP 053 also known as well the
young girl she possesses the innate
ability to inspire delusions paranoia
and eventually homicidal rage in anyone
who spends too long around her which as
you can probably imagine makes it hard
to live a normal life one night the
young girl woke up to something
incredibly strange the door of her cell
typically tightly sealed was wide open
and a strange flashing red light was
shining in through the hallway the sound
of a distant alarm is what had woken her
up what the young girl didn't know was
that the sight confining her had just
experienced a mass Containment Breach as
a result of a major electrical
malfunction some of the most terrifying
creatures imaginable were roaming the
halls in search of violence and Carnage
but when the young girl got up and
wandered out of her bedroom she only
wanted a glass of water to quench her
midnight thirst she wandered down a long
plain hallway washed intermittently and
ran by the red flashing emergency lights
she rubbed the sleep out of her eyes and
yawned all this strange emotion maybe
she's just having a bad dream but what
seems like a bad dream to her is a
Bonafide living nightmare for everyone
around her a few Halls over security
Personnel were being devoured Alive by
SCP 682 SCP 106 the old man had just
dragged a senior researcher into his
pocket Dimension to do unspeakable
things to him and a group of terrified
admin staff are being lured out by what
they think is a group of mobile task
force operatives but is actually a pack
of hungry SCP 939 imitating their voices
still the young girl persisted in her
quest for a refreshing drink even as
security Personnel began to Fan out
through the building hoping to get
control over this rapidly devolving
situation A group of five armed security
officers ran into the hallway and
attempted to intercept the young girl
but the high stress they were feeling
was only accelerated by the effects of
the young girl's anomalous Powers they
started to feel bugs crawling all over
the their skin they started to get the
sense that their fellow security
officers weren't even people but
monsters wearing human skin suits their
paranoia soon evolved into a blistering
rage each of the men pulled out their
guns and began firing at each other
until only one was left standing wounded
but alive with all the others dead the
object of his rage now became the young
girl herself he understood then that it
was all her doing that she made him do
this she was a monstrous little creature
who took pleasure in twisting the minds
of human beings into terrible forms in
reality the young girl had no such
feelings her powers were passive she had
no control over them she even suffered
from some kind of strange mental block
that left her completely unaware that
her powers were even taking effect she
was in a sense completely innocent as
the security officer pointed his gun at
the young girl as she began walking into
a nearby break room he experienced her
secondary anomalous effect anyone who
attempts to hurt her will immediately
die from either a heart attack or a
stroke the security officer suddenly
felt an intense pain sharp and brutal
exploding in his chest he collapsed dead
before he even hit the ground and the
young girl had no idea she couldn't if
she tried in the break room the young
girl found exactly what she was looking
for a classic office water cooler
complete with a stack of plastic cups
perfect she carefully took one of the
cups and pulled down the lever on the
cooler watching her cup fill as the tank
above the cooler bubbled she took a sip
cool Refreshing Spring Water just what
the doctor ordered but the young girl
suddenly looked up shocked to see that
the tank above the water cooler was now
shaking violently as though it was going
to explode what was going on here had
she broken it she stepped back dropping
the rest of her cup of water to the
ground she felt frightened that's when a
crack back formed in the plastic tank
and the water began slithering out not
dripping or pouring slithering as though
it had moved with mind and purpose and
that's because in this case it did the
young girl hadn't just drank any water
she had drunk half a cup of water from
SCP 054 the water nyph a mysterious
sentient Woman made entirely from water
much like the young girl the water nymph
is often a misunderstood anomaly one
that has received far more harm from the
cruel treatment of the SCP Foundation
than she's ever given to another she's a
naturally curious and compassionate
creature whose trust has been abused so
when the contained breach alarm started
to sound much like the rest of the
foundation staff she had tried to hide
and find cover not wanting to fall into
the crosshairs of a far more dangerous
and hostile anomaly she had chosen the
water cooler in break room 3 which
seemed like a genius idea until the
young girl turned up after years of
being experimented on by Foundation
researchers the water nymph wasn't just
about to tolerate more mistreatment
whatever this strange little creature
was who had just consumed some of her
body the water nymph would fight back
and make it regret ever thinking that it
could take advantage of her the young
girl who really had just made an
innocent mistake began to panic and run
as frightening slithering tendrils of
pure water came slithering after her as
the unfortunate security guard
discovered earlier trying to attack the
young girl was typically a one-way
ticket to a heart attack or fatal
cerebral event but seeing as the water
nymph had neither a heart nor a brain
she was invulnerable and the young girl
was terrified she ran out of the room
past the bodies of the men who had
killed each other due to her influence
outside she wasn't even able to notice
them she kept running and the water of
the water nymph came slithering after
her the water nymph had never been the
vengeful type but after the abuse she'd
suffered she learned the value of
putting her liquid foot down she would
not tolerate mistreatment even from a
being this small the young girl kept
running Breathing heavily because of the
nature of her anomalous abilities nobody
could intervene and help her
occasionally she had run into groups of
foundation Personnel trying to fight
their way through the chaos only to be
anomalously affected and become part of
the chaos themselves they became violent
deranged monsters and started attacking
each other punching and fighting as they
fell to the ground in a brawling pile
the young girl had to desperately climb
over them as the streak of furious
liquid followed her meanwhile across the
facility The Vicious Psychopathic old
man was hungry from war his mouth
stretched into a wide sadistic grin and
he continued walking further into the
base he would find new victims he would
feel their fear and drink in their dying
screams several mobile task forces were
dispatched from other nearby containment
facilities they'd likely reach the
embattled site within the hour but how
many lives would be lost before then the
death count was already well into the
double digits after all this running the
young girl was getting tired it was rare
that she needed to truly avoid and
escape a threat like this and as such
she wasn't exactly prepared for such a
scenario she found her way into a broom
closet and locked herself inside hiding
among mops and brooms she tried to quiet
her breathing holding a tiny hand over
her mouth ready flashes continued to
occasionally illuminate the corners of
the door she breathed in and out in and
out with something waiting outside the
young girl gasped as water started
bubbling underneath the door it started
looking around her feet then rising up
from the ground to the young girl it was
astonishing the water was forming the
shape of a woman standing right in front
of her her lower lip trembled with fear
for a moment she was at a loss for words
then she gulped dryly and began to speak
in a soft little voice I'm so sorry I
didn't mean to hurt you I promise I was
just thirsty the water nymph tilted her
head slightly confused did this tiny
child really mean this was it an honest
mistake after all the terrible things
that had been done to her the water
nymph had difficulty trusting humans but
as the young girl started to cry for
reasons she couldn't quite understand
the water felt the urge to comfort her
perhaps she wasn't with the foundation
perhaps this girl was just another
prisoner they were allies not enemies
while the water nymph couldn't speak as
a show solidarity she began to transform
she got smaller herself becoming a
little girl made of water almost
mirroring SCP 053 she raised a hand and
waved the young girl giggled seemingly
put at ease it' been a long time since
she met a new friend around here and it
seemed like the water nymph was ready to
change that maybe they could escape this
place together the Young girl opened the
door and the two of them ran out
together passing through an adjacent
hallway the young girl ran while the
water nymph slithered formless along
behind her they managed to sneak around
and avoid detection from the many
anomalies and Foundation guards duking
it out for Supremacy in the chaotic
Halls of the facility in a sense it
provided the perfect cover for the
unlikely Duo to escape this bizarre
situation but they weren't out of the
metaphorical woods yet first they were
cornered by a trio of paranoid guards
all wielding handguns however the young
girl's nightmarish ambient ability came
in handy once more the three men lost
their minds and started killing each
other giving the young girl and the
water nymph more time to escape and keep
moving though they were about to
encounter the deadliest threat of all
the young girl took Point leading the
water nymph down the nearest hallway
when suddenly
scp-106 the old man emerged from the
wall right in front of her he had such
anomalous malice in him that the young
girl's Powers was was effectively
useless against him he grinned and
approached her his arms extended ready
to Ferry her off to the nightmare of his
pocket Dimension the young girl had
never felt so afraid until suddenly the
water nymph slithered in between them
and she assumed her full humanoid form
once more forming a wall between the
young girl and the old man this turned
out to be the perfect way to save the
young girl's life scp-106 has
historically found liquid barriers
incredibly confusing and it's been
widely considered to be one of the few
ways to effectively delay the old man's
Rampages seizing the moment the young
girl turned and ran away the water nymph
had just saved her life sadly for them
neither the water nymph nor the young
girl escaped that day the mobile task
forces arrived and took control of the
facility again recontain the various
anomalies who had escaped but even if
they never saw each other again the
water nymph and the young girl would
forever remember how they helped each
other on that in incredibly strange day
now go check out SCP 053 young girl and
SCP 054 water nymph for more of today's
anomalies